to say that something is real is to say
that it doesn't change in time that it's
permanent in time so the idea that the
self is an illusion what is meant by
that claim is it's not permanent in
time an Nan V is a professor at San Jose
State University and focuses his
research on areas where analytic
philosophy meets Indian philosophy today
we discuss several topics one of them
being modal epistemology epistemology is
Justified belief or the study of
knowledge and modal epistemology is the
possibility and necessity of such
knowledge sometimes people reference
possible worlds in this discussion yet
anan's Research indicates that if we
rely solely on louisian semantics for
such discourse well it can be limiting
in other words what do non lisian modal
semantics as seen in some Indian
philosophical traditions bring to the
table the point of toll is not to cover
people who are guaranteed views because
of their large name but rather to
unearth to the public hidden gems like
Michael Levan or Gregor chaon that is
these Titans in the academic world but
little known outside it it reminds me of
a comedian Patrice O'Neal or an early
Larry David say in the'80s names that
Comics knew and respected but not much
of the public knew about Anand is one
such individual so many times in this
conversation I was in awe with anan's
ability to cite such a variety of
sources and such a disparity of Concepts
weaving them together with dexterity and
inventiveness Anand is someone who will
become a staple on toe the notion of
phenomenal Consciousness is dominant in
contemporary Western philosophy but
Indian traditions introduce us to reflex
of awareness so that is perceiving
stimulus versus inward-looking
understanding we talk about this
distinction and several more including
dispelling myths about vidic philosophy
and religion we talk about philosophy of
language we talk about Consciousness we
talk about AI talk about free will talk
about math we talk about God we talk
about morality we talk about virtually
every subject that we talk about on
different episodes of the toe podcast
but all together together in one I don't
think that's ever happened before this
is one for the books and I'm so excited
for you all to hear this or watch it I
almost forgot if you're new to this
channel my name is Kurt jongle and this
is a podcast called theories of
everything where we explore different
tolles different theories of everything
primarily from a mathematicsphysics
perspective but as well as taking a
philosophical one and attempting to
understand the role Consciousness has in
constitutive law or emergent law you
should also know that every single book
every single article every video
everything that's been mentioned will be
in the description and this is standard
in every single toe podcast we
meticulously take timestamps and we
meticulously take show notes enjoy this
podcast with Anan
viia welcome Professor it's an honor to
speak with you again we met about 7
months ago this has been quite a while
in the making yep thank you very much
for having me on it's I'm really happy
to be here all right what are you
working on these days and what excites
you about it so currently I am enjoying
a sabatical which academics you know
pretty much like because they got some
time off to do their own research so
I've been away for six months from the
US traveling all over Europe and I'll
eventually be going to Hong Kong and
India and I'm working on basically two
projects the main project for my
sabatical is an investigation of
classical Indian theories of knowledge
in particular perception and how they
relate to 20th century analytic
philosophy debates about perception so
the book is currently titled on
certification and it's a development and
engagement with the 14th century nanaya
thinker Gesa and how his research uh is
important for looking at contemporary
debates in the 20th century between top
figures in epistemology such as Tyler
Burj John McDowell Timothy Williamson
Christopher peacock um people like that
so basically the goal is to sort of show
people how doing cross cultural
philosophy across Indian philosophy and
analytic philosophy leads to a very
engaging conversation where we get to
see similar ideas discussed in a
different way and different ideas
brought to bear on things we thought
they wouldn't be brought to bear if we
just came from one frame so that's the
substantive project which I'm working on
and I've been working on those ideas for
over a decade traveling back from India
to the United States every year to work
with people in various parts of um India
and in research institutions in America
as well uh then the other project I'm
working on is kind of a separate
interest that uh led to how we met each
other actually it was Susan Schneider at
mindfest who sort of invited me to come
out and talk about Consciousness and
Indian philosophy and in particular Jane
philosophy but I had reached out to her
to talk to her because i' had been
working on this crazy idea that machines
can have emotions and it's obvious how a
machines can have an emotions and
everybody's just simply like forgotten
that there was this theory that if we
explored in more detail and developed it
would lead to a substantive argument for
why machines can have emotions so I've
now developed that uh research in detail
and I'll be going to Hong Kong in
November to uh present my research to an
AI group there and in relationship to
that the side project is that I'm trying
to give an account of why we should
think of artificial intelligences large
language models machines in general of a
certain kind I can Define
as having some kind of moral standing
independently of the fact uh that
they're sensient so I I try to approach
the issue of moral standing by avoiding
the issue of discussing sentience and I
instead focus on other properties that
are relevant for moral grounding and
I've been working on this view also for
two years so these are the kinds of
things that actually Susan and I were
talking about when we met and then I
also explained to her about the Indian
philosophy stuff and she liked that and
so I came out and that's how we met Kurt
so yeah so those so those are all going
on right now project on Indian
epistemology and analytic epistemology
and sort of this deep kind of like side
project that I just like a pure passion
project where I just really want to get
it out there about this thing about
machine emotions and moral standing in
artificial systems that doesn't depend
on the standard criteria of sentience so
machines can have moral standing
independent of if they can feel and if
they can feel is a synonym for sentience
I I think for me sentience is not
actually a very useful term there are
two fundamental terms that I think are
more useful it's the distinction between
affective and phenomenal Consciousness I
typically take it that when people are
discussing sentience for example people
like Peter Singer that it's kind of the
same as just the notion of affective um
Consciousness so yes my view is that um
it's kind of interesting because I'm
saying machines can have emotions but
they don't have affective Consciousness
in terms of the feelings but they still
have moral standing and so when you say
that people are like wow that's kind of
not the result I would think someone
could come up with but that's kind of
what I'm working on what's the
difference between affective and
phenomenal Consciousness oh so typically
what we say is that the phenomenal
Consciousness has to pertain to there
being a subjective what it's like aspect
to the experience the most common way of
explaining this is through contrast so
there's something it's like to see red
that's different from what it's like to
see green there's something it's like to
hear F minor versus is to hear G minor
so those contrasts give us this sort of
like there's something it's like and
then aective Consciousness is typically
argued to be when we have phenomenal
Consciousness Plus what's known as
hedonic tone so there's some kind of
pleasure or pain that is related to the
actual what it's like experience so in
some sense if you think affective
Consciousness can occur you think that
almost every phenomenal state if not all
of them has some sort of hedonic tone to
it so this is the question of
separability can there really be what
it's like to experience Red without any
sort of hedonic tone whatsoever is it
really is it possible that that could
happen so one view says yes this is the
view that David chers has argued for in
his book reality plus and there's other
people who say no like some Buddhist
philosophers would say no every sort of
what it's like correlates with some
amount of hedonic tongue
in it right and so that so that's the
difference between the two definitions I
would have thought that it would be the
opposite where Indian philosophers would
say no you can have phenomenal
Consciousness without hedonic tone
because you can get to states of feeling
like nothingness except maybe quote
unquote being but that's not the same I
don't think I don't think that um so
that's very uh insightful and I think
that's correct so I think maybe I
misspoke I just meant to say that there
are some Indian schools a specific
Buddhist school that would I think it's
the Abid Dharma school to be more
specific that actually has written about
the relationship between affective
States and phenomenal States so I might
be incorrect in labeling Abid Dharma or
Buddhism but in general there are some
schools I think that will say that
there's a onetoone relationship between
that and um there are other ones that
might say it is possible to be in a
full-blown phenomenal State without the
affective tone um I can even think of
some examples and reasons why but but
you're correct I think it's important
just to stay clear with the fact that
there are roughly nine if not up to 28
identified schools of Indian philosophy
and so I tend to like cut try to be a
little bit more than generalizing yeah
now to be a bit more pedantic use the
word one to one and so both you and I we
have training in math correct I mean
mathematical Logic for me particularly
that's my man yeah uhhuh so when we say
one to one did you mean to say that
there are some schools of Eastern
thinking or Indian thinking that in this
hedonic tone firstly let's just imagine
it as onedimensional and pain is here
and Pleasures even if that's false just
for the sake of this that red gives you
five units of
pleasure okay so that's one way we can
have the map but further if I was to say
to you you have experienced something
that gave you five units of pleasure you
can then infer that it was red
oh no right that's that's I get what
you're saying yeah no I don't mean to
use a notion of a bje between two sets
right so that's right there's a
surjection and there's an yeah that's a
surjection and injection and that would
be a bje and that's usually that's
called one to one and on tube right so
so right so you were using the injective
notion uh that's correct no um that's
actually that's a very interesting
thesis Kurt I never thought about the
one where you would infer from the
quantity of the hedonic t T that it must
have been in this range of phenomenal
experiences that's a very interesting
thesis but one to make I think it would
be hard to establish in that you have to
be super Discerning yeah but I think the
the more General one is that that I'm
going for is
that phenomenal states have hedonic
character as part of them it's never
really that you're forget about if it's
positive for me it with red a negative
for it's never that you're experiencing
something that it's like without any bit
of hedonic tone one way or another
that's the one I recall certain Buddhist
schools questioning that whether or not
you could just have this pure what it's
like without any um hedonic tone but as
David in his book nicely gives an
example of he wants to say just as he
created the notion of a philosophical
zombie a character that's physical
duplicate of Any Given human being but
lacks phenomenal Consciousness there are
um philosophical Vulcans creatures which
are physical duplicates of Vulcans in
the sense of have S physical duplicates
of humans in certain sense but they lack
all affective States right so they have
phenomenal Consciousness but no affect
so obviously it's not really good to
think of Spock this way I would think
because of the character and the way he
plays out in Star Trek or even data but
but the idea is to create a kind of
thought experiment in which we can
explore the idea
of some kind of hedonic
neutrality in our experience but there's
still something it's like right I think
one way you can also come to see this if
you want to see it more in terms of um
Neuroscience or psychology is by
thinking about the already well-known
phenomenon of pain asymbolia where a
person doesn't have the ability to have
Rich phenomenology for pain sensation
right in such a case I mean you might
think oh I could find a way to imagine
from this actual case someone for which
certain phenomenal States they have
don't have any tone to them positive or
negative because the person has pain a
symbola I mean there's obviously a
couple of steps more that are required
there that when you have pain a symbol
it correlates with some other inability
to have hedonic tone in some way but
there's a way to sort of start to think
and reason that a creature could
constructed in such a way uhhuh now this
honic Tone If I'm saying that correctly
the positive side is pleasure and
negative side is pain is it as simple as
like that one-dimensional case or can it
be that certain types of pain are more
pleasurable can you clarify that so for
instance there's some people who algolia
okay okay you get sexual gratification
from inflicting or experiencing pain and
then there's the dovian quote which says
I've only in my life carried to an
extreme what you haven't dared carry
even halfway and what's more you found
comfort in deceiving yourself and
mistaken your cowardice for Good Sense
perhaps after all there's more more life
in me than in you and resentment why
ises purification a most stinging and
painful Consciousness the feeling of
insult will Elevate and purify the soul
so I ask you which is better exalted
sufferings or cheap happiness so in
other words pain to him
in some cases in some characters can be
more pure than General positive AFF and
this pess is somehow more
pleasurable more worthy yeah so I was
going to say that it sounded to me like
um there are two ways you can analyze
this sort of dovian phenomenon one of
them would be to say that the value
metric associated with the affect being
positive or negative can pull in the
oppos opposing Direction so that
sufferings which have a negative hedonic
tone can sometimes have a higher value
and in virtue of the anticipated higher
value or knowledge of the higher value
the subject can have a sort of an
emergent phenomenon of pleasure on top
of the suffering I'll give you a really
really odd example but maybe this is
correct I mean I used to lift weights a
lot and sometimes when you're in the
weight room and you're doing what's
called like a maximum press for for the
week like you're trying to test what's
your maximum bench press like I mean it
can be it's pretty painful like but
there's like this moment when you feel
like oh I might actually you know hit
225 today you know uh and so I don't
know if that's the ex I don't know
doesn't seem like what D talking no that
was a long time ago thanks but um yeah I
I think um there is something related to
that and in the opposite direction I
think that the sort of like you know low
the the the the fleetingness of the
spike in the High um hedonic tone of
pleasure can be fleeting in a way where
the value same value metric would say
it's not and we should make this clear
like you know although we started with
me talking about some stuff about
Buddhism I mean Jeremy benam had a rich
theory of pain and pleasure in
relationship to value in his utilitarian
calculus which Mill eventually developed
in more detail but the other thing I
would say that's really interesting here
is there was a a period of time where
one of the big debates was concerned
about two thesis one thesis was known as
the distinction between higher and lower
Pleasures right so that there were
certain kinds of Pleasures such as
reading dovi over drinking 50 beers
which just intrinsically in virtue of
what it is was just a higher pleasure
and there was no way to say if you drank
100,000 beers that'd be the same as
reading Crime and Punishment right okay
so so then there's this question about
what is the theoretical way to make
sense
of that sort
of the fact that they seem to be both
Pleasures but there is no quantitative
basis in which one can equal the other
in any way that became a complicated
question in new utilitarianism then the
other one was related to the scale you
mentioned it was about the fact so not
the fact the question of whether or not
the scale is onedimensional with going
increasing in One Direction and
decreasing or whether or not there are
two different things so at one period in
time there was notion of a Hedon and a
doore okay so a doore was a unit of
negative like paint and a Hedon was a
positive thing and they didn't have to
be on the same scale then the other view
was kind of like the way in which we say
there really isn't cold it's just the
absence of heat right there really isn't
pain there's just the absence of
pleasure right or there isn't really
pleasure there's just the absence of a
certain degree of pain right so this
understand of light and darkness uh hot
and cold and also pain and pleasure at
one period in time was something that
was discussed within utilitarian
philosophy in terms of its ethical
Theory and how calculations were
supposed to be done I haven't kept up
personally with this literature for a
long time but but you're some of the
questions you're asking are
interestingly exploring that that
important area of these
theories you mentioned up and down or
hot and cold or good and bad pleasurable
in pain and there are some schools well
some major schools of Indian thought
that suggest that that's some illusion
so can you please explore that and the
quote that I gave you via email of David
ly who delineated different types of
non-dualism and I know you said you
weren't able to get the source of that
neither was I I don't know where I
copied that down from however some
commenters suggested that no multiple of
these are the same like if you do not
have that distinction between subject an
object then that is the same as Unity
with God it's probably useful for me to
delineate what I meant I had written
down these notes on nism from what David
ly had suggested that there are five
different attributes of them so number
one monism that all separate objects are
indeed of one Vellum number two advita
the subject and object are the same
number three no negation or non-
negation that is one isn't supposed to
think in terms of good bad up down or
any pair of opposites but rather that
they're supposed to quote unquote
transcend the pair number four is edva
that is that there's no difference
between the relative and absolute truths
as defined in Zen and other Buddhist
inspired traditions and number five
mysticism in other words Unity with God
often we think of non-dualism as being
the same but there are different sects
that do not see overlap and in fact will
accept two or even one and reject the
others Anand viya also talks more about
this in his solo talk on theories of
everything which is linked in the
description on going Beyond non-dualism
in the Indian tradition something to
note is that the zoom call of Anand was
out of sync with mine and so there were
quite a few overlaps where I wasn't sure
if he was done speaking so I interjected
and he did the same for me and it sounds
like we're interrupting one another but
that's merely due to that pesky
technology called the internet okay okay
so um it might be useful because that
information isn't available to everyone
right this moment I just draw a
distinction at the outset that can help
clarify some of the issues in the tax
omy that he offered so so so the
distinction I would say is helpful in
the beginning to start thinking about
Duality is Duality due to language or
conceptualization in the human mind and
Duality that is in nature right so I so
the reason why I think like this is
because so the reason why I think this
is useful is because it is is part of
the argumentation of even some of these
Indian traditions as well as Western
Traditions to think that what's going on
is that the mind is operating by
creating dualities and that it's
imposing those dualities on things which
may or may not be dualistic in
themselves so we can think about a
transparency thesis and an opacity
thesis and I'm using these terms
generically not in terms of how they're
defined in the philosophy of language so
a transparency thesis would tell us
something like when we apply a duality
such as good and bad that Duality is
actually transparent to the fact that
there are goods and bads in nature
itself and an opacity thesis would say
something like the fact that we
conceptualize something in terms of hot
and cold doesn't mean that in nature
there's both hot and cold because as we
already know it's just the absence of
kinetic energy in One Direction right so
we can then we can complexify things by
saying the global version is that it's
all like the hot Cold Case right we're
it's all opaque like we're we're doing
this all and then we can have the
moderate case which says no actually
sometimes when we are using dualities
there's a duality in nature it's not
just a function of our language we are
getting and then there's the further one
which probably is the least plausible of
all of them is that all the dualities
that we create are real to some degree
it's just a matter of figuring out what
is a level of reality so that one
depends on a levels-based theory of
reality as well as the fact that we
can't really be getting things wrong
when we create dualities our mind
doesn't impute things in such a horrible
way that it distorts things there must
be something out there that it's
capturing even if we're
misdescribed going on is that we thought
that there was two underlying phenomena
but we found there was one underlying
phenomena but then our distinction just
is mapping different uh gradients on
that one line but it's still mapping
something it's not mapping the
fundamentally so we we were mistaken but
so those are the three different ways I
would say you can think about this
General distinction about the
language sort of dualism caused by
language or concept use and then let's
go to the other side now dualism in
nature like so someone like dayart who's
classically identified as a dualist I
would be hardpressed to think that
anything he said has to do with the fact
that he you know spoke multiple
languages and read in those languages
he's not making a linguistic thesis he's
making a claim about the fundamental
nature of reality in terms of the
essential properties and arguments that
are telling us that what is going on in
one case is that you have a substance
that's identified by by the essential
property of Rage causus thinking and
another one that's identified by the
fundamental property of extension which
is then given also the idea that it can
be infinitely divisible and those
divisions are something that pertain to
it but doesn't pertain to thought and so
he's not telling us something about
language as much I mean I'm sure there's
some critics who think that there's a
linguistic background to the way in
which he comes to it but I don't think
his thesis is about language as much as
this is about the way the world is now
if we take this into opposition with
some Buddhist schools they would pretty
much be saying oh these things are
basically we're creating dualisms based
on our language basically what comes out
as fundamental in nature is not
dualistic in this way we are imputing
the dualisms through the fact that we
make Concepts and concepts are in a way
creating boundaries between things that
don't exist right so there's a there's a
way of articulating this they're not the
only ones that say this and not all of
them say it the same way we have to be
careful here but it is it is an idea
that I think is useful in relationship
to whatever ly is picking out because
what we're trying to say here is that
there's kind of a thesis that has to do
with language and there's a thesis that
has to do with what language is
ostensibly about usually which is
something external to it language isn't
self-referential although we can talk
about words in a metal language when we
talk about for example is running is a
predicate uh that that that's not the
same kind of thing that's going on when
we're talking about dualism in the world
so we sometimes say in philosophy that
there's the metaphysics of reality in
which some people occupy a dualist
position such as dayart and the Sania
School of Indian philosophy and then
there are other people who would say but
then there's also another type of thing
where people are talking about Duality
created by language and they they're
really just talking about how language
works and the way in which it divides I
think actually although I'm not an
expert or even that knowledgeable about
it I think various people in um
Continental philosophy have explored the
version of using um duality in the
structures of language people like Dara
and others have used this to explain and
understand how language works and what
we're doing with language um so I think
it's it's available in multiple
schools if one was to say that all the
dualities that we perceive are created
by us and it's not intrinsic in nature
but then at the same time believe that
nature is mind so that we're one with
nature then how can those two be made
consistent because if you're saying look
it's just made up in my mind it's not
reflective of reality but then at the
same time say reality is mind so then in
some sense the dualities are inherent in
nature so how does one make sense of
that or can they not with
language okay okay so maybe we uh maybe
we sidebar the ineffability thesis for a
moment because I think you you're you're
gesturing at that it's very important to
talk about but I first want to get into
the first part about the tension claim
that like there's something in tension
yeah so let me try and run the argument
this
way mind and nature are one and the
same mind creates conceptual dualities
but because mind and nature one and the
same those conceptual dualities exist in
nature correct yeah nice I like that
argument that's actually cool um yeah so
when we say and this goes back to
answering actually part of your other
beginning question about these schools
in Indian philosophies so I'll answer
that about God and unity now I'll try
and bring that back in So when we're
when someone says premise one for
example the mind and nature are one and
the same at least one way in which it's
articulated in the ADV vant school is to
talk about the difference between the
true self the oton and the fellow
embodied feeling of a self that occupies
us when we reflect on it so I feel like
I'm the agent of my choices I feel like
my body is separate from your body I
feel like my body is separate from the
things I'm sitting on and looking at in
my environment I feel like an agent
right those are things that are part of
the felt sense of self or what we can
say yeah I mean the felt sense of self
and things we attributed to it and then
what adians will say like shankra is
that there's also an Atman the true self
okay and so when we're saying thesis one
premise one the mind is part of nature
what we what is being asserted there is
that the true self is identical with the
one and only thing that exists which is
Brahman and that is the thesis of how we
he would understand mind is identical to
Nature now we say number
two mind creates
conceptualizations we've now moved from
the true self to the embodied true self
with a felt sense of self acting sorry
as an actor in the empirical world in
the world in which there are are
presented to us other things of
diversity right it's that one that is
making those things so then when we draw
the conclusion we have here the fallacy
of equivocation between the truth self
and the felt sense of self and the only
way to avoid the equivocation is to say
that the true sense of self plays some
role in that felt sense of self doing
what it does and I think in there in
that move right there there's a lot of
interesting things to be explored and
there someone could could push the claim
that actually yeah they're still part of
nature in some way so what's going on
here in terms of these issues about god
um and because it's part of what you
asked I want to address that clearly is
that there isn't really an automatic
need to say that if the true self is
identical with the universe or the one
true thing it's in Union with God
because there is a theistic and an
atheistic interpretation of the identity
claim I see so if we so so actually I I
wrote a paper on this recently for a
book coming out so the thesis is Atman
is Brahman which is uh defended by sorry
it's interpreted by two different
thinkers in the vedantic tradition one
is shankara of the ADV vant school and
another is ramanuja of the vishista
viant school a later school that
criticized the earlier school so the
earlier school is called non-dualism ad
literally nonuel and the other one is
called vishishta ADV which means
qualified non dualism or I have a
different way of interpreting it but the
main thing is it's not it's not the
non-dualism of um of shankra sorry
before you continue when you say
qualified non-dualism do you mean to say
it's not as nonu as the advita tradition
like there's some qualifications on it
or what oh oh sorry okay but okay so so
the so okay okay so part of the issue
here is that um that is the common way
in which if you looked it up or talked
to most Scholars of religion they would
explain to you what the word visha ad
means in English however in my work and
in my papers I have avoided using that
term precisely for actually the reason
you asked I don't think that that's
going to help people by saying oh it's
like a lesser degree of it or no there's
another way which is called which has to
do with the internal braiding of the
relationship between the one and its
parts this is actually the one that's
closer to the one to the idea I like and
it's tied to a notion that ramanuja
discusses with which is called aidi so
this is a very important metaphysical
notion in uh ramanuja's work but before
we get too far let me just finish yeah
the first kind of part I think that that
that is useful here is
that within the tradition there are ways
of understanding who is going to be or
what is going to be God so Brahman is
God and Brahman is the only real thing
because it's permanent in time and
unchanging in Shankar's system and when
you discover that your true self is one
and the same with this thing that's the
claim of the nonduality the non-duality
is that what you are and what this is is
one and the same thing now that would
automatically imply something about a
union with God or a non-separation from
God or a true identicalness with God if
it is the case that you had a specific
interpretation of Brahman as a certain
kind of thing that is God this is this
is the issue here that's technical in
the literature is that um some people
want to have a very robust kind of
personalized sense of God like a a
person like a God as a as a person or or
thing like of that kind and in shank's
system that doesn't seem to be the case
it seems to be like Brahman is this vast
field of fundamental Consciousness and
it doesn't have any personlike qualities
to it it's it's only essential property
is that it's an it's Bliss right that's
basically what it is and and so
ramanuja doesn't like this idea and so
he has more of a personalized conception
of God where Rahman is kind of like the
Supreme person in a way and so there's
that that thing so that's why I said to
you when you asked me this question I
said I would not
say that you are forbidden from
distinguishing between the union thesis
and the theistic thesis so I think you
can say a is bman is Brahman but what
that means is not a union with God and
you can say the other one otman is
Brahma and what that must mean is a
union with God and and basically so some
people might want to argue specifically
about then who are using the terms
Brahma what schools are they coming from
and what do we mean but in general I
think just the thesis of identity
shouldn't apply something about God
because I think someone who for example
has a certain atheistic sort of view of
the universe might still think that what
we fundamentally are is part of the one
and only thing that is the universe
right that's right and there's a lot of
ways to work out that secondary thesis
uh so it shouldn't be off the table for
an atheist to take it so that so that
takes care of that sort of question
about like whether or not we should see
Union thesis as always ones relating us
to God now it turns out that in a lot of
cases um
this will be true that that something
like this is being argued for but I
don't think it's
required when we met you
mentioned that there was an Indian Prime
Minister who said we're going to make
non-d dualism the pizza of India oh yeah
so can you talk about that and also talk
about some of the misconceptions that
many people in the west have about
non-dualism okay I I I I remember I
remember conversation because I was
recently just having um Pizza dinner
with my
uncle I was having dinner with my uncle
in uh London and he was asking me to
teach him some stuff about Indian
philosophy and I actually explained to
him this very same thing because it's a
very good thing to understand so for
lack of a better
analogy uh I'll say it the same way I
said it to you basically and I hope your
audience finds it humorous but I think
it would be really bad if we walked
around thinking the greatest
contribution
of Italian cuisine to the world was
pizza and pasta because there's so many
wonderful things in Italian food that
just don't have to do with pizza and
pasta for example I was watching a show
yesterday about umbre and lentils and
how interesting it is and what you can
do with umbre and lentils and making
Italian salads and I found it totally
fascinating and super interesting to
think about making for myself so it's
the same thing um radak Krishnan uh the
first sort of major figure of philosophy
to step into the global space he was the
Spalding chair of Eastern religions at
Oxford in the early part of the century
um at one point kind of made a decision
that um he kind of needed to like
explain sort of what's the big
contribution that Indian philosophers
are making to the world and he tended to
have an advian idea about it he was kind
of like well this is the one thing we've
got this non-dualism it's in this one
school
and he kind of presented it's not like
he didn't know about the other schools
for example let me just make that clear
he very much was one of the
main people who put together an actual
book a source book in Indian philosophy
with Charles Moore that contain like all
these texts and everything so he he was
vastly knowledgeable highly skilled
rhetorician an outstanding scholar but
he made some choices about what to
present and he decided that this was one
of the things that he wanted to make
clear to other people about Indian
philosophy it turns out that as he
already knew that it's incorrect to
think that this is the only School in
vant first of all specific so ADV vant
has become synonymous with viic thinking
in a lot of the places outside of India
and even in India that's all that people
know that's completely wrong there are
several schools of vant the one I work
on is actually the one from ramanuja
which is called V said V there's AAA
there's there's MVA there's a whole I
mean there's it just goes on it
literally just go there's like a lot of
these little sub schools and they have
very different views about what's going
on in the Vic tradition so that's one
thing then the second thing is that ADV
vant became kind of a lens where people
would then look at the philosophy of the
yoga school and try to interpret it
through AIC lens when its actual Roots
were in the s
tradition it's a sister School of the
Sania tradition and so Sania and vant
are not the same in a lot of ways even
many of the schools of vant are
different than Sonia but there was a
tendency to try and like interpret even
Sonia in relationship to yoga through
viic eyes and so this became this this
large Enterprise and one of the things
that came along with this um was kind of
this idea
that this school is highly spiritual and
so this is like the vast depth of the
spirituality of the Indian tradition
coming forward and there was little
attention paid to the fact that Indian
philosophers had other attributes as
well that were also interesting and good
and what did some of those things have
to do with well one of the things that
they had to do with was rationality and
logic that for example is very important
the other thing that it had to do with
was uh theories of knowing the other
thing it had to do with was realism
about the world as opposed to idealism
about the world so I predominantly work
on what's known as daa school which is a
realist School uh and it's an opponent
of various forms of Buddhism and I work
on ramanuja because he's a realist
actually unlike um shankra who's either
an Illusionist or relative realist so I
tend to think that the Indian schools
that were engaged in realism had
something to offer as well and they have
interesting ideas and debates with these
schools that are more idealistic and
they offer contributions that are less
welln and sometimes it's so it's like
the thing like oh we're going to go get
pizza we're going to an Italian
restaurant we're going to go say some
Indian philosophy we're we're going to
learn some Von that's basically kind of
what I told and I don't and I want to
make it clear I I don't know enough
about the political situation of the
time period in which R Krishan was
coming I know he's an extremely aidite
scholar and I don't blame him in any way
for what he did there might have been
political issues going on with the birth
of India that made him think hey this is
you know something that's important
because I can put the spirituality of
adva in so he wrote this book where he
talked about how spirituality is
consistent with science he actually a
title of the book science and
spirituality and so he was concerned
with wanting to you know make things you
know better but his the person who
replaced him at Oxford kishna M was a
nayaka and so he uh for the next longest
time time basically expounded on the Nia
school and the relevance of it to
debates in contemporary epistemology and
logic he studied with vwo Quin at
Harvard University and was a
contemporary of PF straon at Oxford he
wrote perhaps my favorite book in Indian
philosophy perception and essay on
classical Indian ways of knowing um
which is a phenomenal work that engages
a lot of um uh analytic philosophy of
the time period as well as Indian
philosophy and is also the inspiration
for my continued efforts to follow
by developing theories of perception and
Indian philosophy along with um analytic
philosophy now so that's a little bit of
like the story line that I think is is
common among Scholars to know that that
this there was this change of sort of um
things and now there's become like a
reemergence almost of interest in ad
vant because of the Contemporary debates
on theories of Consciousness so in that
Air Field what has happened is
as you saw when I came to mfest at
Susan's conference there is a growing
interest in the fact that some of the
most contemporary moves being made in
debates about Consciousness such as the
pan psychist versions theories promoted
by lots of people nowadays um have
strong resonances with very important
Trends in Indian philosophy and so
there's a lot of work being done now to
understand how that conversation can
unfold as well boy you said like a
litany that's just f
thanks there's quite a few threads so
one of them is there are some people who
watch videos like this and they're in
the west and they feel like they know
plenty about the east or Buddhist
Traditions or viic traditions because
they've watched Alan Watts or maybe read
a couple books and done psychedelics and
they have this Insight that's fairly
prevalent in these circles that
rationality and logic are the opposite
of what you need in order to get some
handle on the truth or reality and you
just mentioned that rationality and
logic is something that wasn't
advertised as coming from the East it's
more the non-dist ADV Vite vienta that
was so can you please expound on that
and then also there may be a couple
terms that come up that when they wait
do you do you just to clarify you want
me to expound on what the relationship
is between these the the development of
rationality and logic in India and its
relationship to these other
non-dualistic ideas yeah yeah the fact
that you can understand not just with
irrationality and experience but
something analytic something logical
when I say understand I mean get to know
oneself or get to know reality or get to
know God or religion or spirituality
because it's generally seen as two
approaches one is more experiential and
one's more analytic and the West is seen
as more analytic and the East has seen
more experiential I'm painting broad
Strokes I'm just saying yeah I'm sure
you see this as well yes okay and while
you're explaining this some terms may
come up like Illusionist or idealist or
realist or relative realist when they
come up naturally explain them please
okay sure thank you that's a that's a
very good question and I think it's
um it's something that I think my
experience in writing and research can
sort of um shed some light on in an
insightful way so one of the things I
think that is a nice place to start is
by looking at a common
interpretation on presentation of
Buddhism in the west uh it's also found
in India but where a lot of what is the
standard sort of thing to talk about
there is mindfulness meditation it is
taken to be something that has spent
sort of undergone a lot of
neuroscientific Investigation I even
know some of the people who work on that
stuff it's also something that has
attracted a a wide audience uh various
different types of people and there's
something about mindfulness meditation
that's healing it clearly has this
property for lots of people and there's
a tendency to want to be interested in
this component of Buddhism uh not
negatively in the sense of like I'm just
going to put everything else away but
just you know that's the thing that's
that's that's the pizza for Buddhism
basically
um so one of the things that I have
found in my research and I actually uh
wrote a fairly large piece on this
actually because I spend so much time
thinking about it was that it is a not
historically accurate at all to think
that Buddhists weren't involved in the
development of logical ideas or that
they themselves did not engage in some
of the most vehement arguments with
their opponents so dakiri is considered
to be Danga and dakiri are considered to
be two of the most
important uh Buddhist
philosophers after ngara uh and the
Buddha himself obviously uh and they
spent a lot of time thinking about the
rules for proper reason and about ways
of knowing about the world um their work
is not so much presented in the
discussion and conversation about
meditation and how to live one's life as
you might find for example with people
who talk about Shanti Deva so pemin has
a nice book about Shanti Deva and um I
think a lot of people go to these kinds
of works or they go to the works that
are talking about what to do with the
stuff that arises in Consciousness in
terms of living a life and being
compassionate and um these are first all
I'm just I want to make it clear to your
audience like in no way am I disparaging
that I have spent time myself meditating
I Rec to go to a Buddhist center like
two times a week I've done vipasa in
India and everything so on L right
now so but but but the the thing I want
to say is that it is just factually
incorrect that they weren't engaged and
thought logical reasoning was very
important the evidence is just too much
and in fact I can point you just to one
780 page book by Daniel Peru which is a
study of reasoning methods within the
Buddhist tradition within the mamaka and
Tibetan Buddhist Traditions it's an
extremely powerful book it might not be
accurate about everything that they came
up with but um it definitely shows the
rigorist the analyticity so the
analytical nature right of their minds
and I think it's very clear that
actually learning to argue and learning
to understand your own emotions through
meditation and motion regulation are two
things that Buddhists care about I I
don't I think that the the thing that
you know pushing the sort of one line is
a an incorrect thing but that doesn't
mean that for example you can't be like
well the thing I'm coming here for uh is
to get some peace and comfort I don't
think there's anything wrong with that I
I just think that like yeah so I think
that's one place where you're going to
find this sort of um incorrect
representation of like you know how
rationality is present in the one thing
that people be like oh but the Buddhist
had it all right because it's like all
the conceptualization and everything in
our mind and all that analytic stuff is
is really bad well sure there is that
storyline but I mean there is also this
other stuff where like they're sitting
there arguing with other schools trying
to figure out what is the best way to
make a logical argument there's a debate
between the James and the Buddhists
about what is the proper uh way to
understand valid inference it's a very
intricate debate it's very wonderful so
it's just it's just not so that's number
one I would say yeah number two that's
directly sort of like the the the
showstopper often times is this idea
that
idealism is prevalent or more prevalent
in Indian philosophy and materialism or
reductionism is not and that is just
factually incorrect the charvaka the
charvaka school is a very prominent
School of Indian philosophy that's in
conversation with various Hindu schools
of the six of them roughly that there
are the Jane school and the Buddhist
school and they're around for quite some
time I don't have the exact records
correct but I have a friend Ethan Mills
who worked on charvaka and he probably
can inform us about the exact like
correlation of when they were around and
they debated people and they totally
have like a hardcore materialist theory
of the mind uh in the sense of I mean I
I I I don't want to use illusionism
which I'm going to talk about soon uh to
describe them but maybe there's a
version of the kind of evolutionism that
you find in contemporary philosophy
floating out rather what I think they
have is this sort of tuning thesis that
it's just because you sort of get the
the neurons and the chemical things in
the right way to mix in the same way
that you get you get the thing up here
right it's just it's it's like purely
determined by that thing and I think the
example they give is making beer I think
that's the one that like when you put
the right ingredients in the right order
the beer just comes that just is that
it's just like an an emergent property
but it's just coming right out of that I
think that's kind of what that so I'll
tell you jardan Ganer has an excellent
paper about
emergentism in ancient Greek philosophy
and in the um charvaka School in basati
I teach this paper all the time it's a
wonderful read it's so interesting to
see how he portrays the sort of
importance of this school and then you
can see wow it's I will never ever again
say that there is no kind of like strong
materialism or something and that's cool
so that's number two and then the third
one I think I already mentioned is the
fact that there are various schools so
there are two schools of mamsa the
prakara and the B and uh then there's
another realist school which is called
the niaya and then there's the vesa also
so of those schools some of them in the
at least in the prakara are realist in
some sense more than being idealist so
what do we mean by realism here in the
context of classical Indian philosophy I
think that perhaps the easiest notion to
go with is the idea that there are
objects in the world independently of
our mind and that our minds come into
contact with them and most importantly
at least in my understanding of it is
that those things we come into contact
with
constrain the way in which we can
think right the things out there are
constraining in some ways the way we
think the idea that we have a complete
free play of imagination and the
capacity to impute whatever is of the
fancy of our mind onto anything is more
of a kind of idealist sort of move and
it's one that is resisted strongly by
the Nia school that is not their sort of
uh way of thinking about things and so
they have a lot of interesting ideas in
that area so let's bring in illusionism
now so illusionism at least in
contemporary analytic philosophy is kind
of defended and articulated by Keith
Frankish and it's kind of the idea that
the phenomenal properties in my
experience are elusory and the claim is
or at least what we need to understand
is in what sense is the what it's like
aspect the phenomenal properties of
seeing red for example an illusion right
so in what sense is that an illusion so
that's kind of like you know the
illusion Illusionist in contemporary you
know um analytic philosophy of Mind
illusionism in Indian philosophy can be
understood differently and it has to do
with a different idea it has to do with
time okay okay so things that are said
to be
elusory often times are said to be those
things which are not permanent in this
is extremely true so so so we have this
like I wrote this book review of um
David Cher's book reality plus where he
defends the idea that a digital things
are not Illusions they're real also but
I brought it into conversation with
shankara because I thought that
Shankar's definition of what is real was
one of the definitions of real that
David's book didn't really address he
was addressing more common sense Notions
that are found both in Indian philosophy
and in Western philosophy such as that
to be real is to be a difference to have
causal power right that's like a common
notion of what we mean if you have
causal power you're real in some sense
right cause things right yeah but in in
Shankar's system and and also in other
ones to say that something is real is to
say that it doesn't change in time that
it's permanent in time so the
idea is for example in Buddhist
philosophy that the self is an illusion
because what is meant by that claim at
least one of the main claims is meant by
it is it's not permanent in time because
this is super interesting like
everything you're saying gez Louise
there's been like 10 over the course of
the last 10 more than that over the
course of the just this one answer right
so you want me to elaborate on this one
yeah but just a moment it sounds like
there's so many mistranslations
happening it's as if even with the word
God so when we say Unity with God the
Christian may say oh okay so they're
talking about my God but it's not as if
those two concepts are yeah that's right
they even know about one another and
then when they say yeah the world is
pens the world is just made up of pens
and you're like okay well it's made up
of this but then they mean quills that's
a poor example but you get the idea real
is impermanent so this cup is not real
because maybe it'll melt one day but
it's real in another sense it's real
we're holding it and then another
sense science may use the word real as
fundamental but then there are also
Notions so that's where I was going to
go right now I'm glad you brought that
up that's a precisely the relevant
difference so um what is going on if you
want to see a very nice contrast is
exactly what you just said Kurt that
fundamentality is a way of saying that
something is real so if you're saying
it's fundamental you're saying at least
that it's not reducible to something
else and secondly that it has
explanatory power right those are two
things about saying so and so in in a
lot of parts of contemporary analytic
possible to say that something is real
it's like you're kind of banking on
saying it's fundamental has explanatory
power and it's not reducible to
something else so when someone says that
your phenomenal properties are an
illusion at least part of what they're
saying is that they're not fundamental
and they don't really have that much
explanatory power given a certain range
of things that we want to say we explain
but in shunka a system that is not
relevant right to be fundamental is one
thing but to be permanent in time is the
important property of being fundamental
right so
Brahman is real it is also fundamental
but what's marking its fundamentality is
that it's permanent in time and not
changing it at a certain level of
explanation that's the thing so that is
you're right there is a kind of
difference that has to do and it has to
do with this thing about fundamentality
and um temporality that's kind of the
contrast between those two Notions mhm
now I know these are from different
areas what I'm about to say but did this
notion of impermanence have any relation
did it lead them to come up with some
notion of
platonism oh so Plato would say like
look so mathematical statements are
Timeless there's a notion of
timelessness and impermanence sounds
like timelessness so would the and I
forgotten the person's name Naru Jan
nager Juna yeah yeah I okay right so
let's let's get get the idea
no I I think I I see a connection so
um yeah so let's get to The Playdoh
thing in a minute minute after we just
clarify a couple of things about this
little area of
um yeah I think it'll be useful to do
this distinction please so the Hindus
and the Buddhists when they are debating
the nature of the self and one of them
is saying it's permanent in time and the
other one is saying it's
impermanent there are actually logically
two different
interpretations that you can take of the
notion of impermanence so number
one something is impermanent when it is
momentary something is impermanent when
it's semi-permanent semi-permanent means
there's a time in which the thing comes
into existence and there's a time in
which it goes out of existence so cups
and you and I are semi-permanent things
under the before we get too
philosophical under this sort of
everyday
definition so
momentary has two definitions also
something is momentary if it has no
duration in
time or its duration in time is fleeting
it's so small okay that it's not worth
discussing but they're at least in
Buddhist philosophy there are two
different Notions of this so now you can
see what's going on many Hindu schools
of philosophy are saying that the south
is permanent in time and then many
Buddhist philosophers are saying well
given that we're constructed of these
five things the scan does and each of
these things Chang it's got to be the
case that the thing you're talking about
is changing and therefore it can't be
permanent so it's impermanent and then
they can go down the road of saying it's
momentary it has no duration in time but
it has a causal succession in a series
between each individual moments like a
line of things or each duration has like
a fleeting millisecond it's actually
it's like they actually try to figure
this called Mind moments actually like
what is the actual thing but I mean
there's two different ways that has no
duration or has some very small duration
uh and then the other thing I'm
introducing is that there's just another
way of thinking about um temporality
where you talk about things being
semi-permanent but this notion of being
semi-permanent doesn't really show up in
the debate so the Hindus and the
Buddhists are mostly debating this issue
about two definitions of
momentariness and a definition of
permanence okay so that cleans up now
the temporality aspects of that debate
now there's this issue you brought up
about mathematics and Plato where you
were trying to talk about the fact that
in Plato system there are some things
that are out of time okay
right so so someone might say in a
platonic theory of mathematics
mathematical objects are Timeless like
so and then again we have to make two
different distinctions here there is one
is being out of
time and being for all time yes Eternal
right okay right so there these two
different and and you're correct there
is this one that says the platonic forms
are outside of time because if they were
in time but Eternal then they could have
some causal relationship to us so
because of this kind of causal inertness
of a certain kind that that we said it
so we always distinguish between
eternality and timelessness now as far
as I'm concerned in terms of looking at
Indian philosophy it is often times hard
to find a place where there are deep
discussions about the philosophical
nature of mathematical truth so that
part of the question I uh I have
actually asked one of my friends who was
a philosopher of mathematics who was
interested in Buddhism kind of like 10
years ago like like hey I've always been
curious like what do you think the
philosophy of mathematics is in Buddhism
and that I don't really know I'm not
saying there isn't any sure I know in
the Nia school there is actually some
philosophy of mathematics but I'm not
sure that it relates to time however the
other aspect of it is correct the
timelessness component does come up if
my recollection serves me correctly I
think actually that
Brahman in Shankar system is outside of
time because it's the ground of
time right so it's outside of time so it
would be something like the timelessness
of mathematical
objects that would be the connection or
the relationship but again it's not the
same thing because at the same time
although there's this timelessness
that's there there's this issue about
the fact that you know um what is the
kind of thing that they are saying is
timeless is is the thing
that's sort yeah it's hard I almost feel
like I caught myself in a contradiction
because because it's permanent in time
which is what makes it real but it's
Timeless because it's the ground of time
but again it's one of those things where
I I would just say like yeah there are
complicated aspects to the theory I
wouldn't be surprised if actually this
is already something that's well known
in the literature on this topic go when
you were speaking and it's difficult to
not get tripped up because of the words
we're using and earlier we had talked
about rationality and iic that they do
have a place in Indian philosophy and
Buddhist philosophy what about
conceptuality and language as well
because those are also seen tied in with
rationality and logic as being
repudiated in the East the conception in
the west is that they so right so again
this is um a misconception no no no no I
won't we we'll let that part go for now
and I'll just say about the the positive
thing that you're actually touching into
there is a rich history in Indian
philosophy of debating the same top
topics that we talk about in uh Western
philosophy that come under the heading
of philosophy of language how does
language work how do we understand
sentences what are the ways in which we
have primary meanings and secondary
meanings what's the difference between
connotation and denotation how is it
that we understand each other when we're
speaking to one another what's the ways
in which our minds are able to grasp the
meaning of a sentence what is the role
of semantic intuition and understanding
all of these topics are very prominent
and also because
Sanskrit grammar itself is such an
interesting powerful thing there are all
these pundits like Panini and batari in
the 5ifth century who have all these
interesting things to say about syntax
and semantics and pragmatics so almost
all of the major things that we want to
talk about or have been talked about and
debated in in Western analytic
philosophy concerning philosophy of
language they find corelates of
discussions and maybe some of them are
catched out in different ways so this
answers the part that says is there a
presence of discussion of the way
language Works in relationship to
reality to be found deeply in Indian
philosophy absolutely almost every
school is heavily invested in giving
some account of how language works now
you might as you did ask like well what
does that have to do with this other
thing about like whether or not
overcoming how language controls the way
we understand reality leads to some kind
of Liberation and you are absolutely
correct
these things are going to be related
they are and okay now I'm going to give
you a wider explanation of why they're
related in Indian philosophy across the
board there is a general tendency to
give a theory of something because it
pertains to this other big question how
do I get out of suffering okay so like
like like what's the the going question
back in the history of when all this
stuff gets off the ground well the
question is life sucks how how do I get
out of this suffering okay so if I'm
giving a theory of knowledge or a theory
of language those things will be
expected to be tied at some level in my
school or in my debates with people to
these questions about Liberation right
so something in the Buddha's thinking is
telling him that if we recognize the
impermanence of the
self we can release ourselves from a
kind of suffering if in the Jane system
we can understand the many sidedness of
things we can come to see the nature of
reality and Truth in a way that maybe
can ease our suffering right now now
sometimes that connection is made very
explicit sometimes it's not made very
explicit but is there an expectation
Within These systems and by the way
they're called dasan and it stands for
world view because they're supposed to
be comprehensive uh systems of
propositions that are networked together
and mutually support each other as a way
of understanding reality and putting us
as a place in there I see I see where we
can where we can see how our so like
like like this is the way things are
this is my world view and as a
consequence of that I can understand how
to uh get out of my my suffering so yes
it is correct now some specific ones now
I'll go very specific for example I'll
first mention shankara will say
something like the the kind of thing
that's going to get you to
really release in a lot of ways is to
see an identification between the true
self and Brahman and I think the term in
Sanskrit is Brahma gyana which is like
sort of the Insight of this uh Brahman
and so this has becomes interesting
because now we're going to get into a
very important argument here in his view
is that knowledge of this kind cannot be
in the subject object structure okay so
ordinary experience in the world has a
subject object
structure but because of the identity
between the true self and Brahman the
knowledge of that cannot have a subject
object structure as a consequence this
gets to your ineffability
issue nothing I can say in language
could strictly speaking be correct if
it's articulated in the positive form
if I say if I say it in a positive form
I apply a predicate to a subject that
puts it in a subject object structure
but it fundamentally isn't a subject
object structure so there is some kind
of
ineffability about and now we can
actually if you want me to I can go into
three different kinds of ineffability
found in Indian philosophy but but the
idea is that that the experience is
nonel although most western philosophers
following brentano like this is what I
talked about at mindfest would say that
experience is essentially um subject
object Consciousness is always
consciousness of something that's the
very famous line that you get from
brentano and so what would it mean to
say I have a nonu
experience look you can actually Kurt
can you hear the the audity and what
would it mean to say I have a non you
see right so this is the kind of thing
like what I can't articulate what this
is because it's non-u right so um so
right so then there are questions about
whether or not those experiences are
valid are they forms of knowing because
if someone argues that knowledge is
always subject object but this school is
telling that there's a kind of knowledge
that is non-sub object is there a way
for us to rationally assess something
that transcends the way in which logic
can be applied as an evaluative metric
because logic applies evaluatively to
things in a subject object structure and
this thing you're saying so what is the
way to that and this gets us
into discussions uh so one of the terms
that you might have heard before is
yogaja praka which is a special Insight
of the yogan to see to see something
it's a kind of like a an intellectual
seeing but then again it's not a seeing
but seeing as a subject object structure
and so there other thing um other terms
that are used in Sanskrit to talk about
it uh and the basic idea is that there
are experiences that just don't have a
dualistic structure right and that leads
to a certain kind of ineffability um
okay so I I'll let you ask me a question
unless you want me to expl expl more you
want me to keep talking about
ineffability theories sure please yeah I
can give you two different versions of
ineffability or three I think there is
okay
so so okay I'll give it to you in a very
simple way you can understand so suppose
my
experience this is a very easy example I
think I that's why I like this example
suppose my
experience is rich in the following
sense anytime I describe it to
you were you or I or an ideal version of
me to reflect longer we could describe
it in more detail that's still true
right so like I start now and I say okay
uh my experience right now is of uh two
screen a screen that's split in half
with on and on one side of Cur on side
like okay true and then I say oh but
it's also of kind of one color on the
left side and one color on the right
side true it's also of the color Hue
magenta on the left side on the right
side white you see we can keep getting
deeper and deeper and
deeper okay so so on this view uh
experience is Rich and every time we
give a description we can find another
description that's more precise and true
but both descriptions are are true now
why is experience ineffable because we
can never get the complete description
this is called ineffability by
completion incompleteness I can never
give the infinitely Rich description of
my experience even if it at every level
of describing it it's
true it's not the case that I'm going to
exhaust it and get to that infinite
description so this is so sorry is this
argument in principle argument or like a
practicality argument like in
no so that's a very good question I
think actually the way it's run is in
principle I do not think it's run in
terms it's not like oh we're going to
get tired in a 100 hours and basically
then on like no so there's kind of two
versions in the in principle one and in
the in it's definitely not the Practical
one it's the ininal one but then there's
also two versions of it I it's that
there are an infinite number of
descriptions and we're never going to
exhaust that because we're finite
creatures and also that there are a
bunch of descriptions we don't even know
what those are yet that we could
discover them and make it right so
there's one like a discovery version of
it we're discovering more and more about
our experience and know like they
already exist all the concepts we're
never going to do it right so those are
two different versions of the in
principle one but I want to bring to
your attention the fact that this seems
to be about truth being present in the
description of my experience but never
being able to complete it so what is
ineffable is the complete true
description
okay that's one version now let's go for
another completely different version
there's another version that says no
what's going on is that every time I
describe my experience I put it in
language the language makes it appear as
if it has a certain structure inherent
in it it doesn't have that structure
because it doesn't have that structure
what is literally said is false of
reality sorry it doesn't have the
structure of reality like language has a
structure to it yes the the Lang yes the
right so I'll give you a a specific
version of
it when I say there is a horse in front
of me I use the universal horse and
apply it to the animal in front of me
that might make it seem like there are
these things called universals in
reality but as some Buddhists will argue
there are no universals out there in
reality there are only particulars Shana
there's only these particulars out there
in reality and because there are only
particulars in reality and no universals
when we express things in language such
that are Universal it deludes us into
thinking that there are these things
there and what we say in some sense is
just literally false right there is no
Universal out there there's just a
particular right and so on this version
the true nature reality is in some sense
ineffable because when we put it in
language to speak it we falsify what's
there do you recall where you were just
continue yeah I know where oh yeah okay
um yeah so in this other version what's
kind of popping out as Salient is that
the
representation of what is in reality in
language
falsifies
what's really in reality and so when we
mean when we say it's ineffable it means
that the structure of language just
distorts in a way where it does not
express what's really there and we don't
have any other way to do it it's not
saying like in the first one that that
we it could be the case that our
descriptions are all true we just can't
finish it and therefore it's ineffable
because it's unfinishable it's saying
that it's ineffable because the
structure of the thing we put it in
always falsifies it right okay and so um
yeah that's the second version now
between these two
versions there is another version which
doesn't have to do with
falsity and
incompleteness but it has to do in part
with the difference between truth and
falsity right so okay on this version
It's ineffable because some of the
things we'll say about our experience
are true and some of the experience
are false and when you conjoin something
that's true and false by the rules for
conjunction you get a false statement
right so so the the second one was kind
of saying no matter what we say it's
going to be the case that it's false
because nature language
fundamentally puts something there that
isn't there um and the first one said in
those cases where we're truly doing it
we're never going to get to the complete
one the third one says that more often
than not we're doing we're saying things
that are true but also we're saying some
things that are false and because the
truth and falsity con join together that
ends up with a false conjunction I see
yeah that last one sounds super subtle
so that one yeah has a name it's um I
definitely I call them the one by
completeness incompleteness that's the
first one then the second is is the one
by the falsity of the structure of
language and the third one is by the
mixed cases the truth and the falsity by
it's by by the fact that that
descriptions conjoined together in
sentences form a conjunction and
conjunction requires all conjuncts to be
true yeah yeah that's what it is so now
again you wanted to sort of get into
like where you know sort of the
spirituality aspect of this can be seen
sure and I think that part of that
answer in some of these schools is that
if you constantly are stuck in the
analytical mind and you're thinking
you're constantly trying to understand
your reality in a way that is inherently
full of dichotomies that will make
things seem true to you that are in fact
false and then by reducing your
analytical
Tendencies and focusing on something non
analytical or stopping the
conceptualization in your mind is a way
to get to a form of peace and
Liberation okay so that's one way I can
see a connection here that's definitely
propounded in some of these schools in
different and actually you know it's
useful for me to point out that I'm
intentionally not giving names to all of
these ideas like oh this is this person
from the 8th Century who said this
precisely because I think these ideas
are straightforwardly understandable
like nothing I said I believe is
something so complicated I mean that you
can see there's a difference between
incompleteness F by structure and mixed
cases like that's that's all we need
right M yeah okay three questions I'll
throw them both out I'll throw them all
out I mean and then you'll just tell me
which one you want to answer most okay
so one is about suffering and much like
we use the word real as sometimes
meaning impermanent or sometimes meaning
fundamental or sometimes meaning
something else does the word suffering
in the way that it's being used in these
Indian traditions and Buddhist
Traditions doesn't mean the same that we
think of here so when they're saying we
must eliminate suffering or this is in
order to eliminate suffering or this
AIDS the elimination of suffering is it
the same kind of suffering so I'll put
that aside I've written these down but I
want to say them so you have time to
think about them as well another one is
about the incompleteness argument and
that reminds me of Daniel dennet who
said that Mary in Mary's room could have
the experience of qualia if you were
able to explain everything to her so the
thought experiment is that she's blind I
believe it's that she's blind and you
have to explain what blue is
and Daniel Dennett said yes you can if
you give enough facts it becomes
isomorphic to the experience of blue and
I forgotten that argument but if you
know that argument then I wanted to hear
your take on it if you don't then we can
forget about it and then number three
was about chsky Chomsky was saying that
most of the words that we use we think
they're referencing something in
external reality but they're not they're
referencing something in mind so for
instance he uses the word River and then
he talks about the river that's near him
it's now empty there's no water flowing
through it but we still call it a river
and if they paved over it they may still
call it a river and so the word River
can refer to it but it's not exactly
this flowing water that we think it is
it can have multiple aspects but then he
said but that doesn't mean that it's not
real it just means that it's not
referring to something external and that
there's a reality to the words that
we're referencing in our mind so for
instance there is a painting behind you
and just because we can't explicate what
a painting is precisely doesn't mean
that painting is not real like we have
some intuition that we're conveying with
one another that maybe that intuition is
correct or real and doesn't mean your
wife isn't real doesn't mean your kids
aren't real or your father just because
they're not fundamental and so on or
just because they're not independent of
Mind those were the three the number one
the suffering doesn't mean the same
number two Daniel Dennett and number
three
Chomsky oh I'm gonna do all three I like
all three I think that's I think that's
that's a really good question so the
first one uh let's uh the word in
Sanskrit I that's most commonly used is
duka that's the term actually I believe
that the Buddhists are also using um I
think
that there are connotations sorry
theoretical considerations in certain
Traditions when they talk about Dua that
don't occur in the mind of English
speakers when they are using the common
sense notion of suffering so I'll give
you the one that I most often
discuss
um I'll ask as a
question if you were exalted and happy
right
now
because uh something wonderful that
you've wanted for a long time in your
life happen just imagine that particular
thing whatever it is it doesn't have to
be money or it's whatever you want but
that thing happens now yeah and Kurt has
it and Kurt is
flooded with happiness exaltation tears
of
joy would you say that in the moment
when that's happening you're also
suffering h no that's right so I think
the English use of the word
suffering would think that that is a bit
incoherent right right I do think that
there are some Indian traditions that
would say that in those moments there is
a way in which you're suffering because
you are clinging to the temporal
duration of the sensation which is
essentially impermanent you will not
feel that exaltation forever yet in
virtue of having that Joy tears of
happiness or whatever is going on the
ineffable happiness of Kurt's moment
there will be some clinging Psych
logically to its futured continued which
essentially can't happen and the
clinging involved in the feeling of
happiness is suffering itself because it
is essentially going to be
frustrated uhhuh okay so that I think is
clearly a way in which the
concept of suffering via Dua is used in
certain Indian traditions
that is not what we're talking about
when we're talking about
suffering in um in the English context
and another way to put it is that often
times in English when we're using the
word suffering we already recognize the
difference
between uh accepted and unaccepted
suffering so when I'm bench pressing and
it hurts I accept the suffering as a
necessary okay good a necessary pain for
that I
want unaccepted suffering when somebody
goes and smacks me over the back of my
head and I'm in pain and I don't see
what's going on at all so we already
accept that and when we when we use the
claim and we say we're suffering in
English we almost always mean it's of
the unaccepted kind right we're never
right suffering right so so our uses go
that way I think that's commonly what we
mean and I don't think that that we take
into consideration the idea that this
idea of clinging to the Future
continuation of an exalted state of
pleasure uh is a form of suffering and I
I do think Buddhists have a lot of
interesting things to say about that in
other words it's a synonym of clinging
to
suffering which is why they have an
emphasis on letting go which is the
opposite of
cling I see what you're saying
um I don't think it's synonym is not the
relation that comes to mind I think
maybe more the idea
that suffering doesn't apply just to the
temporal
moments it applies to the relationship
between the temporal moments of the
state of mind and its futured uh like
what's going to come next right so then
to them in principle like if there was a
way that you could feel happy forever so
you got whatever it is you get or maybe
getting doesn't matter to you it's just
some State someone waved a magic one
wand and you like this moment that you
like this Bliss that you feel it's a
it's an infinite MDMA pill an eternal
MDMA
pill then would they call that suffering
if in this thought experiment God can do
whatever God wants God waved the magic
hand and or the magic wand and said this
is never going away you don't need to
worry then would they still call that
suffering if they're just based I'm just
saying this is so hypothetical maybe
they don't even think about no I I it's
um I just want to know because I'm
trying to drill down on would that still
be
considered yeah I think it's a good
question I think I think it's also first
of all I think it's admissible that's
the main thing that's important and what
I mean by that is that sometimes
cross-cultural philosophy leads to
inadmissible questions I think this is
totally admissible I see we're going to
learn something about what they're
thinking about temporal duration and the
causal relationships between moments of
pleasure and their future productivity
right so so one idea is that is that I'm
going to now dress up your argument in
like language I would use like like it's
just oh it's just a contingent fact that
it goes away there no essential property
to the pleasure in relationship to me
that it's going to go away so it does go
away and you guys are picking up on that
it's impermanent that's not that's a
contingent property what if it was the
kind that was
permanent uh then how would your
argument apply that we're suffering in
those moments yeah so I I think it does
apply I I do think it does apply and I
think the answer is probably I mean
strictly speaking the answer is going to
be it's just not permanent that's I mean
obviously that's going to be the
argument the move that's going to be
used it's in the nature of these kinds
of things to be momentary that's they
would say it's essential to
it um yes no no sorry if it's in its
nature no no no no no no s I meant yeah
no that's a good point very good point I
think I meant essential to the kind
right that that they're going to go away
the fact that one of them has uh a
longer temporal duration of pleasure
before it hits pain is the contingent
thing but yes you're right the kind it's
in the nature of the kind of Pleasure
and Pain that they will go away um yeah
so I think that that's right so it'll be
a disagreement about you know what
properties of them are essential or not
that's correct I think that's that's
right I mean we go yeah we're going to
get to Chomsky and dennit but let's
linger here just a moment longer yeah
sure our discussion started with this
honic tone of Pleasure and Pain and then
you were saying some schools of thought
see the pain as an independent AIS of
the pleasure so it sounds to me like
they're saying it sounds to me in my
Western mode it sounds to me like
they're saying that if you're on this
pleasure axis that you're inevitably in
some positive value on the negative on
the pain axis like you're inevitably
suffering is that the case
no not is that the case like in reality
but is that what they're
saying so in order to drill down into
that we need to go to a specific text
and person and see exactly what their
Theory so I think I think generally we
can say about what they are saying in a
general sense that's useful I we're
talking primarily about Buddhism here
what we can say about it in general is
that um you gave an explanation and
saying by saying okay there's a scale
right and like it's this way and if
you're on this side it's the pleasure
thing and if you're on this side it's
the pain thing and there's not these two
different things so right so so let we
can give the we can analyze this two
ways we can say like is it the Heaton
doic model or is it like the heat cold
model and and how does that pertain to
its temporal temporality right and I
think that's totally reasonable right
and I don't think either of them
actually is going to help with the
position that it's that their duration
is fleeing and they will go away but if
you want uh an argument that actually
supports this that I think they would
give the Buddhists and I also think
other people would give is um when have
you or heard of anyone experiencing any
type of pleasure that didn't have a
duration an argument by induction seems
warranted here right I for example know
that all my pains and Pleasures have
passed in time everyone I've talked to
is such that their pains and Pleasures
have passed we're all relevantly similar
in this respect so it's reasonable for
me to believe that pains and Pleasures
pass in time buds are empiricists after
all I mean they're very empirical in
their reasoning I mean this is like a I
wouldn't be surprised if they're like
hey this is very good reason for you to
maybe there's some wacky like you know
argument about how like you know you can
derive it from first principles but hey
from our experience it sounds like this
is what's going on you know and and
actually this is the argument for why
the self is impermanent in time I notice
that my conscious States change I notic
since a child my body has grown I no
that my intentionalities change from
moment to moment I no that sometimes I
have pleasure sometimes I have pain so
the five scas are constantly changing
what's the evidence for that what it's
empirical observation right like that's
that seems like so I don't see I don't
think they wouldn't think that that's a
good argument now would someone who is
interested in the possibility of it
through imagination say well we can
imagine like you did in a thought ex
term such a property being such that it
was held and in that case would we be
led to the conclusion that the person is
still suffering on this model and I
think yes it would be harder to say that
because in fact the clinging is never
frustrated it's always
satisfied um but then again I think it
would might break with the fundamental
idea of these um okay so I'm going to
provide a counter example to what I said
and then I'm going to counter my counter
and I want to hear what you think okay
when you gave your
presentation you said that the canvas is
bliss meaning that that when you remove
everything the feeling that's left is
actually a positive one or at least
that's one way of interpreting it and
then someone said yeah but isn't Bliss a
qualia if you're removing qual like
someone had to raise their hand and
asked that question and I forgot what
your response was so forgive me but
anyhow that would seem to indicate that
you can just be on the pleasure access
so that's my counter that you can be but
then my counter to that is saying you
can be quote un quote you're putting
some identity there whereas in order to
get to that state it's extremely
self-effacing to the point of Nirvana or
not being a person or not having an eye
so anyway I don't know if what I said
was correct but please use that as a jum
well first of all I think I think I
think I think you you've touched on a
very um in insightful connection that I
don't think I was going to navigate
towards but which we should discuss
which
is is the
experience in an adviant system of
having the knowledge that you're one
even though it's non-d du knowledge one
with the
rumman isn't that a form of Eternal
Bliss which is not going to
be taken away in any way in time in the
world and also isn't it precisely the
case that it won't have this temporal
duration problem because it's not in the
subject object structure it's outside of
the subject object structure and time
applies on the subject object structure
so yeah I think that that could be a
very solid difference between the the
notion of daa and Suka which is the
opposite and these two schools I mean
I'm roughly I don't I I I put less stake
in nailing things down to specific
people because we're playing with an
idea that obviously we can work out
analytically and what we're saying is
that that that in one system this
experience of non-d du
identity with the one and only thing
whose essential nature
is
anunda why wouldn't it lead to it yeah
actually I'm going to give you two more
things on this that are really
interesting I have my other friend Swami
Medan though who has written about uh
Shri ramak krishna's mystical
experiences uh my recollection serves me
correctly when Shri ramach Krishna had
some of these experience he wandered
around all the time like laughing like a
child and be really happy and some like
as if he was on the permanent MDMA or
something like that so I don't know I
mean there there could be some kind of
like actual examples of like the
testimony of people who observed his
behavior and then in addition I think
what's relevant about your question
maybe we should clarify for your
audience because they won't know what
happened at the talk so it's true that
in in shankra system Brahman is Nuna
without qualities and in ramanuja's
system Brahman is saguna with qualities
so if Brahman is near Guna without
qualities then what does it mean mean to
say that Brahman is such Anand where
Ananda is bliss and Bliss seems
like quality okay so so what I said was
this and I'll I'll unpack it this is a
way of try again this is a way of trying
to understand it in the in language so
analogies are the best I can do here so
one way I think about it is that there's
a color that a canvas has and the color
that the canvas has is white or
off-white let's say okay but clearly the
purpose of the canvas is such that other
paint other things are supposed to come
upon it and that is what's really the
painting the canvas's color is
irrelevant in a way by analogy the
quality of Brahman is Anand which by the
way is not happiness which is a
phenomenal state that we instantiate but
is this is a bliss in a spiritual sense
like you should not think that Bliss as
Anand applied to Brahman is like you
know you being like super happy that's
like not the way to understand what
Anand is but um so what happens is this
is that the the as you strip away the
layers of paint the canvas is revealed
to be off-white as you strip away the
ucer experience and identify as one with
the ultimate Brahman it's fundamental
what's revealed is just pure Bliss right
so that's that's the way that's that was
what I was was telling you and that's
the response I typically give it is
literally in the literature on this view
that there is this kind of contradiction
that like oh it's supposed to be quality
un let's this seems like to be a quality
I I I do think that that is a problem
for shank I'm not a big fan of all the
moves he makes but I do think that this
way of explaining what might be going on
works and also it it works well with the
idea that in the subject object
structure of experience we're going to
have a very hard time explaining what
this is like and that's why it's
ineffable so yeah nicely yeah you've
sort of sort of set up a way in which we
can see Su Dua understood in be like a
more classical Buddhist framework as
involving this clinging that always
leads eventually to more suffering and
so yeah that's like and then this other
system where it's different but again to
answer the basic question I think there
are ways in which it's different from
the kind of in which we use suffering in
ordinary English and so maybe the last
thing I'll say about this before we move
to the other question is this in my own
recent work uh when I'm going to like
for example Hong Kong to present stuff
on machine emotions and the moral
grounding problem I have argued that
there is a different type of suffering
in English and that's called cognitive
suffering cognitive suffering occurs
when there is no phenomenal suffering
but there is a suboptimal satisfaction
of preferences so my view is that we can
properly say of an artificial system or
a creature like an amoeba or a plant
that it is cognitively suffering when
its
preferences aren't satisfied and in
virtue of its preferences not being
satisfied there's a clear sense in which
it could it would be better off if its
preferences were satisfied so the
example often times use are these little
creatures where they need to be in
oxygen rich water in order to survive
and they use uh a detector for magnetic
north and south in order to find the
oxygen rich water so if I put like a a
dummy magnet over it I could like pull
it down into like this horrible
environment right but if I let it do its
own thing with the regular you know
polarity I'll find its way to the right
thing now these are very rudimentary
creatures or organisms but I don't think
that it's really clear that they're
phenomenally conscious but it's clear to
me that things would be better off if
they were an oxygen rich environment
then were they to be a non- oxygen rich
environment in terms of their continued
survival so I would say that they are
cognitively suffering and what I mean by
that is that there are clear preferences
that are there for how their system
functions which would be satisfied in
one environment as opposed to another
one and this Cuts against the English
notion of suffering where people say in
order to suffer you must have some
feeling of pain that's what it means in
English and I think that even if it does
mean that there's a very clear notion of
suffering in English where we would say
even if the person is having sort of
hedonic pleasure they're suffering this
is oftentimes what we say of many drug
addicts right in fact the analysis with
Buddhism is actually pretty clear being
high on drugs just means you're going to
have a clinging an attachment to wanting
more of which you're going to suffer
more because objectively your body is
not functioning properly right so that
same notion that we do there I think
just leads the idea that there's a very
serviceable notion in English of
cognitive suffering and I think it can
be applied to machines for which there
is no phenomenal Consciousness but there
are states of the machine for which it
is functioning
better than it would be in another
environment right so that so let's close
the uh the the suffering one but I think
that you can see like like I would
definitely say like not only in English
is there a different way to do it but
there are different ones in the other
okay so now on to Dan dennet okay
so okay so I don't know this Dan Den
argument so but I do know I do know what
what what is going on here in terms of
the fact that like there are two things
going on in the Mary thought experiment
one is that she's supposed to know all
of the facts
about
um color vision and red with respect to
actually all colors red in particular
she's supposed to know in particular
like what typical objects are red like
tomatoes and fire trucks are red what is
the you know sort of properties and
terms of wavelength Reflections and
environments to make Scarlet versus red
this you know all the different colors
uh and she's a sighted person right so
but she's just grown up in a room that's
black and white ah okay right right so
so so because she's grown up and been
you know it's like like some evil IRB
problem institutional review board would
never approve bar imprisonment but yeah
so she's she just studies all this color
vision
stuff and um you know and then the
question is sh if it just amounted to
knowing all these facts then when she
sees red she should learn nothing new
but clearly everyone has the intuition
that when she's allowed to leave the
room and sees a tomato she learns what
it's like to see red right so that's the
so all the physical facts don't suffice
for all the F so I think the way I used
I used to have a nice way of presenting
this with it's that um all the physical
facts don't suffice for all the facts
about red because the phenomenal fact of
what it's like to see red is not
entailed by all of the physical facts
yeah that's basically what the and
actually most people this is a great you
know thought experiment I have no
problem crediting Frank Jackson for
wonderful work I think it's in Bur and
Russell before though where he talks
about a blind man could know everything
about but clearly the blind man doesn't
know what it's like to see you know
green or something like that and that's
even a quicker easier way to say like
couldn't a super smart blind person just
literally study everything and be able
yeah tell me what's going yeah but but
obviously they're missing something what
are they missing and what it's like to
see red so now the Jackson thought
experiment just inverts it by saying
well she can see but she's grown up in
an environment where she's been deprived
of this but she can't derive it from
everything else so what it sounded like
to me you were saying is that in this
version that Dan Dennett explores he
says well actually it's incorrect to say
that she has all the physical facts in
fact if she had all the physical facts
she can come to derive what it's like to
see r that sounds like the move that's
being done and there is so for example
this thought experiment has been so
heavily studied and debated that there
are many many different um going about
it what oh never mind there are lots of
different ways of of approaching so one
thing is that well um she does know what
it's like to see red she just doesn't
know what it's like to see red under
this description right so this the the
redness mode of presentation right but
she actually does know what it's like to
see red so this there's this move about
like well what is the kind of fact that
she doesn't know and what level does it
sit at right so there's lot so Den it
could easily be operating in the space
of saying one of these things okay so in
general without getting into the details
of what he specifically says because as
I said I don't know um I think the
standard line for me and where I stand
on this is in in agreement that um I I I
don't think phenomenal facts can be
known absent access to phenomenal
properties right so if you're not in
contact with phenomenal properties then
you don't know the what it's like thing
but it is O it is still consistent to
say along with that that there's a bunch
of things you do know that could make it
the case that your behavior is IND
discernible from someone that does see
phenomenal red like I can't think of the
right thought experiment right now but I
would say that I understand my view
probably goes much closer to wanting to
say that what's being done in these
kinds of arguments is that we're
isolating the phenomenal property and
then I'm going to concede that like yeah
like if if you don't have contact with
it you don't know what it's like to see
it but I'm also going to say that that
doesn't mean that your behavioral
Tendencies are going to be completely
impoverished uh there could be other
ways of engaging in the behavior that's
appropriate for when someone sees red
given a society that attribute certain
actions to Red like Behavior or whatever
yeah I would I would think that that's
closer um to where I would go one thing
I would think that dennett's
argument probably doesn't do and this
might be the thing where like if he does
do this I'd be like okay that that
was I don't think it's the argument that
says that if you give them more
information somehow by thinking and
reflecting on the information the qualia
appears in your mind that I don't think
is what's going on right so there would
some people could say
hey Mary does have phenomenal qualia
phenomenal qualia she doesn't have like
she hears auditory Sounds by the way in
the room right so she she has like you
can understand
is not phenomenally deprived she's not
in a sensory deprivation chamber right
she's just not in a place where there's
color right so a person could try to
argue that if you feed more information
there's a way in which they can use
through reflection and the phenomenal
qualities that they have and inkling of
what it's like to see red so for example
she sees edges she sees shapes she sees
black and white she knows that the color
red is in the color spectrum she knows
what those those things are so if you
can imagine and you are vision and your
imagination is Rich you might be able to
come to an
inkling of what it's like yeah to see
red and maybe one way to think about
this is a very famous example from David
y you take a color wheel with uh shades
of blue and then all of a sudden we just
cut one shade of blue in the color wheel
let's say it's going from like light
blue towards like purple let's say and
we cut one at at exactly 50 50% of the
way there and then he asked well can you
come up with the missing shade of blue
this is like I can't remember whether
he's trying to argue against us or for
this but I think he's trying to say you
can come up with it and we can we can
think that this is something that like
Mary might be able to do although it's
hard because the difference between
seeing and hearing and seeing in black
and white and in Gray which could be
derived from black and white seems to be
a big leap to get to Red but this is a
kind I don't think that that would be
the argument that dennet is talking
about because I don't think dennet puts
much weight on qualia in the first place
and so sense he is actually the premier
illusionists of all kinds probably what
he's putting weight in is the fact that
there's a bunch of things that are
associated with redness that have to do
with behavior and those things are
things that someone who has this much
information can successfully carry out
you know yeah okay so that's my take on
that I don't know that much
about chsky so the the Chomsky thing
actually I do know a lot about that was
really interesting that you brought that
up because I actually studied with the
leading externalists in philosophy of
language for8 years I did my
undergraduate education and my graduate
education with the pioneers of what is
known as semantic externalism which is
precisely what you're kind of pushing
against in chomsky's voice so I have
much more to say about the river example
which is in fact um a direct uh um kind
of Riff on uh Saul kpk's example of the
river Dart for Dartmouth in the
beginning of naming a necessity his
lectur from 1971 so I don't think if
chsky gave you that example that isn't
an accident at all the river example
actually is what s kky is actually
talking about in his lectures it's one
of the most
famous um examples and discussion pieces
in all of philosophy of language in the
20th century it's the very famous the
river example he begins his the lectures
that way and so I think it's interesting
to talk about this thesis because I'm
wholeheartedly a semantic externalist I
I I don't even think a unless we get
more details on the table what is
actually being said so I think like is
it the case that in your opinion what's
going on here is that we're never
referring to things out in the world
because if that's the thesis I just
think that's just inconsistent with my
core commitments in philosophy of mind
and philosophy of language it's my
understanding Chomsky says that most of
the time we're not referring to external
and that outside of science it's 99 % of
the time that we're not and we had to
painfully develop science to refer to
the external world and it uses even a
different structure than the way that we
have sentences so formal systems wow
okay so I think most of the time we are
referring to the external World whether
or not the way in which we return refer
to the external world is via something
that is a
representation that is internally
accessible to us let me put an asterisk
on that I think Chomsky would say that
we think we're referring refg to the
external world and we're attempting to
but what we're actually referring to is
within mind or something mind like right
so maybe we should do this like by using
a distinction that's helpful between
direct and indirect reference so I can
say that I refer I use the word
Kurt and Kurt refers to Kurt in the
world but it doesn't do it directly it
does it in terms of a
representation or a way of thinking
that's particular to me in my mind that
then picks out uh Kurt and uh and then
there's another one that says no I mean
when I use the word Kurt given how I
learned the word Kurt it's the case that
Kurt refers to you in the world doesn't
refer via
anything in my mind it might be true
that I also have all these beliefs about
Kurt you know a Canon and stuff like
that but it's not finding its way to
Kurt through those things right so kpy
is a proponent of what's known as direct
reference Theory so one way of like so
like so there was a huge debate for like
uh a huge tradition like starting with
Fraga and Russell going through the
works of sirel and
straon and we call them description
Theory and and the idea was that each
speaker has associated with a given name
such as Kurt iranin a set of
descriptions and if you want to know
what they mean when they use that word
just look at the descriptions that are
in their mind and then whatever those
things pick out that's what the word
refers to right this is the indirect
route right the idea is
that I think I can't remember exactly
who it was it might have been Russell
but under this view names like Kurt and
Anin are just
abbreviations for longer descriptions
okay which are sets of descriptions of
the person who lives in Toronto who met
Susan who on this day did that those
were all in mind so when I say Kurt I
just mean this assemblage of
descriptions in my mind it's a Shand
yeah right abbreviation so I think that
was more associated with Russell than it
was with Fraga and then other people
came along later on they say no it's not
just a description it's like a weighted
cluster like there's a bunch of
descriptions in there and then some of
them I'll be like oh if this doesn't
turn out to be right then I I'm not
referring to Kurt and like you know it's
got to be that Kurt is living in Toronto
Kurt is a podcaster that's secondary or
or maybe I'm the person who says Kurt's
got to be a podcaster I don't care where
maybe I was wrong about where he lives
but my term Kurt doesn't refer to anyone
who isn't a podcaster and so there's
like a waiting like a probability
distribution like I'm referring to this
as long as this one is maximally
satisfying I think this was the the
weighted cluster conception that was
kind of discussed by um uh uh kryp key
but it's found in the work of maybe sure
in rudimentary form seral and straw and
so KY refuted all of these views in my
opinion he took them down in 1971 pretty
cleanly between the early part of
January and the end of January so and
most people in the tradition I study
with think that that is correct so what
is so on on my view um we are referring
to reality and in fact it's even worse
than that because I'm a pretty strong
externalist I think it's that it's in
virtue of the fact that were in contact
with objects in our environment that we
are referring at all referring is not
something that's primarily about
anything in the mind that's just it's
that's backward as a consumer of
language and a producer of language my
uh goals with reference are to get
things uh in my environment that are
part of my community onto those things
not things in my mind I don't need them
to think about what's in my mind I need
them to see that I'm lying don't be
thinking about what's in my mind think
about what's out there the common object
it's something that's a predator for us
so we need to run so I think it's
because of my realism that I think yes
reference is about getting on to things
in the world primarily and secondarily
there's a practice of referring to
episodic experiences like I can refer to
like I had this dream last night clearly
I'm referring to what's in my head at
that point so I think that's right so I
I'm not
sure my impression is that probably you
know when when when he articulated this
chunks he might have been saying that in
fact the the revolution and semantic
externalism is partly mistaken but there
are lots of ways to see the mistake so
for example David chamers does think
that there is a correction that um Saul
ky's view should undergo and that's by
distinguishing between primary and
secondary intentions and meaning and
doing what's called epistemic
two-dimensional semantics so you can be
revisionary you can think okay direct so
one of my teachers Nathan sammon who was
my dissertation adviser is like one of
that key proponents of direct reference
Theory right we're like you know you
know it's just the descriptive content
and all that stuff is just not playing
any semantic role it could be playing a
pragmatic role that's a different aspect
of language that has to do with
communication uh but it's not playing
any semantic role like the names are
directly referential they're tags or
millionis is sometimes called the tag
view Kurt tags this particular thing I
learn this use of the word Kurt by
interacting with you when I was
introduced to you through Susan that
makes the the causal CH in chain in my
mind that leads back to you my use of
Kurt is about you because there a causal
chain directly going from you to my mind
it's about a causal theory of reference
that's basically the view kryp key
announces but it's okay for someone to
say that I accept that we are referring
to external things in the world but I
deny uh the thesis that it's direct as
much as is the degree to which some
proponents of millianism the tag Theory
or the caal theory reference think it's
direct I think it's a little bit more
indirect or at least if there's this
other way that things go on and it
wouldn't surprise me if um chsky is also
sympathetic to the idea that
sometimes I guess what I what I'm
thinking is is I can't I can't sort of
sort of get my head around is when I say
Kurt mhm
let's say your wife says Kurt yeah okay
let's take very good this a classic
example from Lock I think actually um so
when I say Kurt I'm referring to the
descriptions in my mind and when your
wife says Kurt she's referring to the
descriptions in her mind like as opposed
to we're both referring to you but what
we associate with the word or two
different sets of descriptions because
we learned about you in totally
different context and we have a
different relationship with you so I'm
more inclined to say the second one
accurately describes the behavior of of
human beings and how we actually learn
language and and how s in particular
proper names for objects in our
environment is that we associate things
with them and that's completely natural
because we have different experiences
with the things and beliefs about the
things but the the the proper names are
are to refer to these things and not to
to to to just get us back into our head
otherwise
if we all come to believe this then when
I'm talking to your wife she's like yeah
interesting like you have these you know
they referring to your your brain and
she's referring to her brain and so that
okay okay so that's so that's what I'm
saying like I think a let me clarify
it's okay to maybe not go in for the
strong directly referential when you say
Kurt you're referring
tot and you think that something else is
going on I think that's okay but I think
I prefer to describe it by saying that
no when you use a name there's a causal
link that takes that name to the person
and it's true also that you associate
things with that person maybe via
thinking about the name too but that
doesn't mean that the name is referring
to those thoughts as opposed to the
person and those thoughts are about the
person also yes okay good so yeah so
briefly you might want to know what is
the distinction between one-dimensional
semantics and two-dimensional modal
semantics
concerning uh names and uh kind terms
so so um the classic example to be
discussed is uh the example that
um water equals H2O so water is a common
general term for a substance in our
world H2O is a chemical term for a
compound that captures
a substance in our world and it was an
empirical discovery that what we meant
by water in the common term is identical
to
H2O now first of all before we go
further into the actual difference
between the two views nothing I'm saying
depends on whether or not it's true that
water equals H2O like there's some
people who get really hung up on the
fact that actually in chemistry it's not
true that they're these pure samples of
water and water equals H2O so all we're
saying we're talking about a common yes
term in a length and a theoretical
identification that's the important
thing that's at stay okay
so kryy thinks that
basically it's necessary that water
equals H2O and the reason why he thinks
it's necessary and a posteriori is
because water the word water is a rigid
designator that picks out the same
substance in every possible World okay
so there's like a range of possible
worlds okay and water as used by human
beings on Earth were part of the
practice of using this term of water
that turned out to be
H2O are using it as a rigid designat
they don't mean the word to change
depending on what possible World we're
in so water is a rigid desert designator
and H2O is a rigid designator and the
definition of a rigid designator is a
term that does not change its reference
depending on what world we're evaluating
it in so if we now imagine a set of
possible worlds W1 through W6 M Water
refers in that world and H2O refers in
that world in those worlds only if what
say water and H2O are present the things
that are here
and
also as long as there's worlds in which
water is H2O and maybe some worlds where
water doesn't exist we can say that it's
necessarily true that water is H2O
because either it exists in the world or
it doesn't and if it exists in the world
then it's identical because of the way
we're using it here on Earth or it
doesn't exist so in all worlds in which
there is reference water is picking
something out and that thing is H2O it's
going to be true yes so it's necessary
that water equals h because it's true in
all possible worlds in which water and
H2O refer and in addition we discover
this OPP posteriority because we could
figure out water was H2 a prior so this
was a magnificent major moment in the
history of philosophy in the 20th
century that there are truths that are
necessary and aposteriori because it
destroys the contian thesis that what is
necessary is AR priori okay so Kant
famously made the claim the necessity
and AR priori are related to each other
kryy destroyed that thesis by showing
that there are truths that are OPP
posteriori that are necessary now the
difference between Dave's
View and Saul's view comes from kind of
like there's a relationship to this
chomy discussion so I want to say that
there's a relationship to the chomski
discussion but it's more connected to
two different um aspects so we're going
to say that
water is the name and associated with it
is a definite description okay and what
is that definite description the local
potable liquid that flows in 60% of
sorry it flows in all the rivers and
cover 60 to 70% of the earth quenches
thirst is you know the thing that is in
most of our bodies it's like a
description of the characteristics of
water as we use the word right as we use
the word as consumers of water we do
have a common description that is
associated with it and so we'll just
suppose we can call that D1 sure okay
so David's view is that when we
evaluate a possible world we can
evaluate it in two Dimensions we can
evaluate it with respect to its primary
intention and its secondary intention
okay
okay when you evaluate water is
H2O according to its secondary intention
you get the exact same result that Sal
kryy gave us the result that water
equals H2O and it's necessary because
water's a rigid designator H2O is a
rigid designator and that's they're
identical in the actual world so they're
identical in every World in which they
both refer
but kryp key doesn't have what's known
as a primary intention and the primary
intention in David's roughly for this
example is just D it's this description
so if we go to another possible world
yes yeah and we ask what is picked out
by description D the local potable
liquid that fills up 60% of the planet
surfaces in most bodies and is also
drinkable and stuff like that and it
turns out that over there it's XYZ or
wrt then it turns out in that world that
water picks out or water is equal to XYZ
okay so that result so on David's view
it's primary possible that water equals
XYZ although it's secondarily impossible
that water equals XYZ it's secondarily
necessary that water equals H2O but it's
primary possible that uh water equals
XYZ so the idea and actually I spent my
dissertation in six years of my life
working on this Theory to understand it
it's it's a really fun mathematical
Theory but you got to really wrap your
head around some deep mod of logic to
get this stuff going yeah right it's
yeah there's a lot of moving parts to
the actual Theory but I'm simplifying a
lot of ways just to make clear what the
differences in the results are but the
thing is like there are two ways to look
at a possible world and this was a great
Insight that Dave had that I I really
liked this thing you can look at a
possible World from the perspective of
it being the actual world or you can
look at it from the perspective of it
being a counterfactual world so kryp
Key's analysis is all counterfactual
Earth is the actual world and on earth
water equals H2O and these words are
rigid designators so in every other
possible World considered from the
perspective of the earth as an actual
World water equals H2O and if there's
anything else there XYZ and no h H2O
then water doesn't refer in that world
okay in Dave's view though we can look
at the world from two perspectives we
can say what if this world where there's
XYZ is the actual
World in this world if XYZ satisfies the
description of the local poble liquid
that then we must be rationally
compelled to the conclusion that on this
planet water refers to X YZ why are we
rationally compelled because the
hypothesis is that this information set
is the actual world and now we're
looking at the word water relative to
what it would refer to given this
information set and that so it's
basically almost like a basian
calculation basically you're like okay
given that the description D is
associated with water and this is the
information the probability of what's
going to be uh the reference of water is
going to be XYZ XYZ s satisfies the
description right okay so there's actual
World
evaluation and counterfactual World
valuation actual World goes along with
the primary intention okay
counterfactual goes along with the
secondary intention interesting and so
the yeah so this is what it's actually
there's like a lot of cool mathematical
things to learn it's called floating
Point semantics sometimes you know uh
there's this other guy paabo tii who
came before we did some really excellent
work on this it's related to David
kaplan's work on demonstratives it's a
lot of cool stuff that's going on here I
me when I was growing up in like grad
school like this was like all technical
philosophy of language philosophy of
logic stuff that we talk about it's
really fascinating and stuff but his
real insight was to give this nice
little epistemic
interpretation I mean two-dimensional
semantics using modality was already
there but the epistemic interpretation
is unique to Dave because he's talking
about the fact that you can have an
actual World evaluation and a counter
fral world and on based on this you can
actually say it's possible that water
equals XYZ because it's conceivable that
water equals XYZ how is it conceivable
that water equals XYZ well consider this
possible world as actual and take the
primary intention of water equal to
description d d is this long description
and what is the probability of XYZ
satisfying d this world it's 100% so
we're rationally compelled to then
conclude that water is XYZ so it's
conceivable on the primary intention
analysis that water equals XYZ on W3
therefore W3 is a witness to the fact
that it's uh there's a possible World in
which uh water is XYZ so it's primarily
possible that water equals XYZ so we're
so sometimes people say that in Dave's
view what's going on is that there are
one space of Worlds and two intentions
to look at the Worlds at I can look at
it as this is the actual world or I can
look at as this is the counterfactual
world if I look at at the actual world
I'm taking the information set into
itself if I look at at counteraction I'm
looking at relative to another one I'm
saying W1 relative to W2 and in the
other in the actual world I'm saying W1
taken as W1 into itself so he's one
space of Worlds uh this is actually
called The Thesis of um modal monism
there's only one space of possible world
but there's two intentions the opposing
view is that there are multiple stases
of possible worlds and one intention
right so that's the view that says that
sorry the first one was called what
moral realism moralism monism monism is
separate thesis I can explain if you
want but modal monism is a thesis that
there is one space of possible worlds
and then you can add to that the thesis
that there are two or more intentions
for evaluating any sentence across the
space of possible worlds uh Dave takes
two
intentions uh and then you can have this
other view that says no there are two
different spaces of possible worlds
there are the one or multiple something
that's called The Onion model there's
the physically possible Worlds the
metaphysically possible worlds and the
logically possible worlds and these form
of proper subset relations um right but
they're all there's all this this one
like space but they're all they're like
like the metaphysically possible worlds
and the logically possible
aren't the same on this model that's
called modal dualism and um yeah so so
that's kind of the difference so I would
say
kpy
Advanced a
one-dimensional semantics that used
counterfactual
evaluation and he also in some sense
gestured
at modal dualism and after his work
people who were working in
metaphysics heavily were interested in
in
whether what what kind of modal dualism
or modal pluralism followed
metaphysically from the theory he had
advocated so there's a big debate on
that so just to clarify one distinction
the last thing you said modal realism is
the thesis that possible worlds are real
entities of some kind there are two two
versions of this so one version is the
louisian thesis which says that possible
worlds are concrete particulars just
like our universe and the only
difference between any two possible
worlds is basically the individuals that
inhabit them and the fact that they're
uh spatially and temporally not related
to one another so there's no causal
relationship between any two possible
worlds so but they're they're real just
as this is real okay and then um the
other version of modal realism is the
set theoretic Universe account which
holds that basically a possible world is
a certain kind of set it's a set of
sentences that's uh maximal with respect
to every other prop so you you so
basically you use a proof you use this
thing called uh the Linden bombs Lemma
from metalogic that shows for any
consistent set you can build a maximally
consistent set by ordering the
propositions and then going relative to
the initial set is it consistent is it
not throw it if it's consistent put
throw it out
go and it blows real up so it's Linda
bom's L very important proof for doing
the compactness proof and um and
metalogic right uh but it's applied in
the work of Alvin plantinga to explain
the theory of uh modal realism in terms
of sets so there's an infinite plurality
of sets of maximal consistent sets and
possible worlds are these sets of
sentences and the actual world is
different from the possible worlds
because it's concrete it's not just a
set of sentences it's a set of sentences
that obtained right and that's a very
different view than Lewis's view where
what makes two possible worlds different
in terms of actuality is just that when
we say actuality here we're referring to
our world and when they say actuality
they're referring to their world just as
when you say I you refer to you and when
I say ier me yeah okay so those are the
main distinctions that are going on so
Dave is a modal realist I believe so an
mon an aortal Mon
Mon and and a realist of a at least a
moderate modal realist he's a modal
rationalist modal monist and a moderate
modal realist okay so we have a
plurality of descriptions different
definitions and in our world they all
refer to the same object but I could
imagine that in different worlds each
one of them could refer to something
else so given that Dave says that
there's a secondary
intention based on a description well
based on which description to me it
sounds like as soon as you open up a
secondary intention you open up a
plethora of definition
soly through descriptions good so let's
get let's work through this carefully to
show two results on the side um okay so
and and this is kind of even in the
Echoes of like a lot of what kryy argued
about when he said that he didn't really
think the definite description view was
even an accurate description of human
mental life like people don't really
have definite description so like I
wrote my under graduate honors thesis on
this example like Joan of Arc like
so my friend goes to class one day and
falls asleep in French history class and
a bunch of stuff about Jon of Arc is
said and then I call what did you learn
in you know French history class and she
says to me I learned about Jon of Arc I
like what did you learn she's like I
don't remember anything so is it going
to be the case that when my friend said
Jon of Arc her uh utterance had no
reference because she
didn't get a description of any kind in
her mind or even suppose she said I
learned that it's the ice cream parlor
across the
street um now given that she learned
Joan of Arc in a classroom from a hentry
history Professor who was teaching a
tour her we should say her utterance is
caused by the utterance of the teacher
and whatever the teacher is referring to
is the best explanation of what she's
talking about okay okay because that's
the only thing only source she not like
she has another competing source for
Joan of Arc so one of the things that
kryy was trying to point to I think to
that's really kind of important here is
that is it actually true that we all
have substantive descriptions for all of
the terms that we use like there's a lot
of terms that we know how to use and
people would say that's a correct use or
utterance of the word for which we don't
really have much we can and my other
favorite examples what's a transistor
I'm pretty sure that there's something
called a transistor radio but unlike my
wife who knows a lot about you know um
electrical engineering can explain what
a transistor is and a capacitor is but
I'm lost I don't know what a transistor
is am I not referring to transistor
radios no I clearly referring to
transistor radios because I learned it
from people who defined these things and
talked about them so there's this kind
of phenomenon that uh you know Hillary
putam and Gareth Evans talked about who
were you know contemporaries of kryy
called the semantic division of labor
that you know different people are
producers of terms and then we all
consume them in a causal Network where
we learn from each other
so when Dave introduces this idea of
saying well we can take the primary
intention analysis and a way to
understand that is by thinking that a
given description that's associated with
a term like water is going to be now
used instead of water itself because
it's a case in which we're considering
the world as is actual I think all
that's meant to be done there is to show
us that there is a different kind of
evaluation right there's an evaluation
that does not take the semantic content
at the actual world but instead uses a
descriptive device to go help us find
what's in another world right so it's
like asking right right right we know
that water is H2O here but given how we
found water over here by thinking about
this description and then investigating
it what if we use that description in
another possible world uh what would we
have to say is the thing that is picked
out by that so now we introduced the
idea well hey what if we switch from the
local poble thing to every Sports
player's favorite drink after a
basketball game basketball right okay
well maybe it turns out that on this
planet there are no basketball players
so it turns out that that that
description doesn't lead to any desp
Discovery whatsoever right so we can
have a plurality of descriptions we can
acknowledge that there is a relativity
to our answers and there's a plurality
of descriptions without in any sense
violating the Insight of the model
because the model is saying that there's
a dependency relation based on going
primary versus secondary and in addition
it's relativized to the description
we're using uh but the fact that there
are other descriptions we could be using
doesn't invalidate the model it just
means that there will be different
results given different inputs right so
it's just like it's saying that there's
two functions we can use to analys
analyze things and now if you tell me
that one of the functions has a
different range of inputs than the other
one um that's just I think so I don't
know the technical thing about what he
might say about why we don't suffer from
a relativity of descriptions that's a
good question CT I'll probably ask him
next time I see him but but I do think
that that that um it to me it wouldn't I
wouldn't be worried if I was him I'd be
just like yeah that's fine that's
exactly what my theory should allow for
it should
say went to the primary intention what
we were looking at was some kind of
description that guides our seeking
Behavior clearly there are different
descriptions that we can associate with
it but it does turn out that even if you
know KY is right that most people don't
have these descriptions in their mind or
they have very different ones in their
mind based on how they learned something
that when it comes to certain kinds of
Concepts there's established communities
that are
identifying um causal roles associated
with a given thing so remember a lot of
this debate was not about um common
terms that don't play a role and what's
known as theoretical identification we
want to know what light is we want to
know what heat is we want to know what
water is we're looking to theoretically
understand so this is why the chsky
thing you were saying about learning
about science and that doing something
that's why that's relevant I would think
because in fact kryy was talking about
that he was talking about um theoretical
identifications towards uh I think two
and three lectures two and three so I
think it's that is what's going on now
if you say to me that the the the
dominant descriptions that control
investigation of theoretical kinds like
Bon
Theron uh are so open to wide variation
the way in which um something like you
know Kurt might be I'd be a little bit
shocked yeah I would think that there's
a little bit
more agreement so in that sense I think
that we could that there's a way in
saying well the model is open to the
plurality of descriptions that could be
used in a primary intention analysis but
but but but and it would be relativized
to the results of each of those that
doesn't invalidate the model but by the
way it also turns out to be the case
that concerning theoretical
identifications for common kind for
common terms for uh uh these kinds of
scientific kinds like tiger and things
like that there is more or less
something that is in common that we
would want to do the analysis we would
want to know given the description of
tigers here uh that we used actually to
discover what the underlying nature of
tigers are what happens if we go to this
other planet what are we rationally led
to conclude uh in uh this other possible
yeah even in kpk's definition primary
definition of water is H2O this brings
don't say primary no no so so he doesn't
have the he doesn't use primary and
secondary so all he's saying is that uh
water equals H2O is true and we
discovered that aposteriori and I guess
if you want to say definition you could
say that what defines water is being H2O
yeah that might be so cryp key would say
that what defines water as H2O and that
that can pick out water in different
worlds does that not presume that the
laws of physics are the same in other
worlds and when I was looking at your
modality distinctions there was this
hierarchy where you have the physical
world and you have the metaphysical
World outside of that so physics is
nested in metaphysics and metaphysics is
nested in logic so it seems to me if all
of these are possible worlds let's
imagine that you can even view that set
the Su sets as different worlds what KY
is saying is even a subset of physics
the set of physics that is the same as
us which is the set of physics of all
possible physics which is within the set
of metaphysics which is within the set
of logic yeah so this is this is
extremely relevant this is actually what
I
spent this is this is the kind of stuff
that I sort of when I was 22 to 26 would
think about like every day for like
years on end like I I spend all my time
working on this kind of thing because a
lot of what's going on here Kurt is is
that kryy sort of introduced us to the
idea that there might be a partition
between the space of possible worlds
defined as having the same laws of
physics as we in the actual world and
those possible worlds defined by obeying
some logical system such as first order
classical logic and he introduced this
idea by telling us that there's
something called the space of
metaphysically possible worlds which is
such that that certain metaphysical laws
he didn't say the word metaphysical
laws certain metaphysical laws obtain
but there are variation in physical laws
what does it mean for a law to
obtain
um it's a good question I mean I don't
really do a lot of like um I don't think
about it in terms of obtaining in like
the philosophy of science or what people
mean when they say a law of physics it
obtains I think probably what I just
mean is that it's the one that's
governing right so if um okay so govern
by I got it right so I think the way I
mean so this is where like my sort of uh
mathematical logically way of
understanding things comes out I I
literally have more of like okay well
there's a theory T and T has a set of
theorems and axioms and those
exhaustively codify uh you know some
specific version of quantum mechanics
and when I say that this range of
possible worlds is physically possible I
just mean that that t governs what holds
in terms of physical possibility in
those worlds right so one of the first
papers I wrote was not about this one
but about logical possibility I said
well you can say The Logical possibility
is constructed out of paraconsistent
logic you can sayu intuitionistic logic
you could say it's constructed out of
first order classical logic I mean
there's lots of different ways so
example you know if you're building
maximal consistent sets you can use
different relations to build those
things those entities can be constructed
there's lots of ways to construct them
and so if you think that possible worlds
are just these abstract objects that are
real and concrete in a sense sorry real
and particular not concrete because
they're abstract um then you can we can
talk about them in terms of a really
important you know set builder relation
or like ma like a logical relation so I
would say the same thing I mean if you
can tell me two different theories of
physics string theory and you know like
many world interpretation and that those
two things have very different you know
fundamental things that they say as part
of the core of their Theory then I can
say that this set of possible worlds is
physically possible in virtue of the
fact that it satisfies t for string
theory number one and this one satisfies
the many world's interpretation and
right and so I I just I'm I'm basically
labeling these spaces based on
what theory they are basically yes uh
consistent with or or satisfying yeah
that's what what what we mean now the
the part of your question that is like
on everybody's mind and like Dave spent
a lot of time doing amazing work in this
area along with other people form is
that there is this uh post cryan
tendency to either inflate or deflate so
let me explain that so
inflation takes it the case that the
physically possible worlds inflate to
the metaphysically possible worlds so
that what happens is that there is no
notion of metaphysical possibility that
just isn't physical possibility and that
idea is just the idea IDE that there
really are no metaphysical laws that
aren't physical laws like all we're
talking about is that physical
possibility just is metaphysic and
actually krippy had a sentence I believe
it's in lecture three towards the end of
the book where he said it might turn out
to be the case that physical possibility
is a possibility to core I think that's
the actual meaning two core two core
meaning like it's it's the absolute one
like that's the one
that so I think the idea is for me as I
read it back then was just that
physical possibility might just turn out
to be what metaphysical possibility is
there's nothing more to talk about
metaphysical possibility other than
physical possibilities so once you have
your correct physical Theory let's say
it's many worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics plus whatever you need
to do other fancy things then you just
know that all the metaphysically
possible worlds are just the ones that
are consistent with that theory in
physics would it be all right if you
gave an example of what someone would
think this is a metaphysically possible
world but it's not a physic possible one
so that they see the absolutely
absolutely yes yeah so this I've been
because I'm a proponent of the
distinction I've been asked this
question several times by people who
have tried to to um to push me on it and
um to make you an
inflationist no no in one way or the
other I didn't explain deflationism but
I'll give you the example anyway in the
beginning so
um you know I always forget the name of
this person I feel so bad if he
published this paper in a very famous
journal the Journal of philosophy um and
it has to do with something in physics
actually but um the examples I remember
is that um there's a certain kind of
particle Decay where what happens is
that the particle spins either lift left
or right and mathematically everything
is equivalent it could just spin the
other way right and so the what the idea
is is that there's a metaphysically
possible world where all the
mathematical things are exactly the same
as it spins in the physically possible
world's consistent with our physics but
it just spins the other way that's
that's the actual and I think that is
probably the least investigated example
uh in this debate but I think that
example that was published in the early
2000s is I think his last name is is
Mario his first name is Mario buo goio
he's an Italian guy I just thought it
was a brilliant example but but the idea
is that you have mathematical structural
explanatory
similarity but you have the opposite
spin direction from the particle Decay
it just goes in another way so that's
like an easy example so the idea is
generally that something in the physical
case is staying the same and sorry the
physical laws is saying say but
something else is occurring now there
are other types of examples too those
are examples where we say something is
metaphysically necessary even in Worlds
where the laws of physics are different
so here's an example of that like
someone could say that it's
metaphysically necessary that water has
a capacity to be at least a
liquid vapor and a
solid so even if the laws of physics are
different nothing's going to be water if
it doesn't have those phas properties
okay that's going in the other direction
that physical laws can change although
something has so for us to be talking
about what to be referring to water is
if that's a bit more controversial
because you might is that not just
conceptual modality rather than
metaphysical okay yes it's useful if I
explain the deflationary sure right
because that's the two sides of the coin
okay so the inflationary
approach is to take the things that are
physically possible
necessary just say that's just exactly
what the met so so again it's an onion
physical metaphysical logical inflation
physical to metaphysical one to one
right there's no difference yes
deflation is to basically take the
metaphysical Into The Logical right okay
sorry now that logic is nested in
metaphysics no no no no that the the
metaphysical correlates one to one oh
correlates one oh I see I see got it so
so now it's so so first it was physical
inflates to uh logical to to
metaphysical and now logical deflates to
metaphysical yeah yeah it's going down
right and so then so in both cases
what's really happening is we're getting
rid of metaphysics it's called
skepticism about metaphysical modality
Grand priest has a really nice paper
about this now in this move this other
one the deflationary one is wherein
lies the move about conceptual
possibility so there's two Notions of
logical possibility one is called narrow
logical possibility and the other one is
called broad logical possibility so
narrow logical possibility has to do
with logical possibility that's solely
determined in terms of the ax theorems
and axioms of the system itself right so
for example in first order logic you
might have the law of excluded middle
that's
explicitly an axiom of the system okay
or or theorem or a law of the
system broad logical possibility means
something like logical possibility in
the narrow sense plus all the conceptual
truths can you repeat that once more
please okay so logical broad logical
possibility
means logical possibility in terms of
the narrow sense of just talking about
the laws of a specific system but then
you're adding to it a bunch of
conceptual truths and you're applying
The Logical system to all the conceptual
truths so classic example that was Deb
was like it's a conceptual truth that
Bachelor equals unmarried male okay so
now we add that as like a theorem like
all the conceptual truths become like
little theorems after we have the law of
excluded middle and you know something
like modus ponin then we add in oh here
so now this notion of logic is the kind
of logical possibility and necessity is
the it's telling us that well the
conceptual truths are just additional
pieces of information for logic to
operate on but they are in some sense a
priori right so logic is a priori
independent of sense experience and the
conceptual truths are just the sorts of
things that we add in so one conceptual
truth that someone might talk about in
the case of water is that water is a
liquid or or that's a gap like so so
they might put that in there but water
is H2O there's a question is that a
conceptual truth it's definitely not a
priori it's aiori okay so this is how we
get into things so when you want to talk
about conceptual possibility that's
people could say conceptual p is
conceptually possible if and only if p
is consistent with the relevant logic
that's being used and the set of
Concepts in
question right so in each case we're
relativizing the modality to a kind of
thing that um
like determines or adjudicates the
possibility or the necessity claim right
so physical physical laws metaphysical
metaphysical laws concept conceptual
conceptual truths and stuff like that
there's a by the way there's a really
great paper on this issue by one of my
favorite philosophers his name is kit
fine he teaches at NYU he wrote a very
famous paper called the varieties of
modality or varieties yeah varie of
modality and in that paper he discusses
a lot of these important issues in a
nice way and talks about different ways
in which you can talk about it so this
is a very important debate in in an area
called the metaphysics of modality which
is a subset of um The Flossy of modality
but yes okay so like yeah so there's
three different kinds four different
kinds you can talk about and then also
by the way there's other ones like some
people say well isn't there a notion of
technological possibility right right
right like what's technologically
possible now is not what's
technologically possible in the future
what was in the past there's so there's
various specific and then there's a
further debate about what then are the
the basic kinds of modalities so like
we'll say there's a plurality of
modalities are any of them joint carving
like are we all making them up in our
head is it is is all this stuff like is
it real these distinctions or are they
artifacts of our mind so Dan's view is
very much focused on um I mean like I
I'll say what the the the thing is that
I think is going on but um uh I don't
want to be too forceful in saying like
this is the only way to interpret it
sure I think on his view the space of
metaphysically possible worlds just is
the same as the space of logically
possible worlds metaphysics isn't really
metaphysical possibility isn't really
something differentiable so he's a
deflationist would that be called being
deflationary in my terminology it is in
the way I write about it it is but I
mean other ways of talking about it is
just that he thinks that metaphysical
possibility amounts to
logical possibility broad logical
possibility involving the conceptual
truths and someone like me uh or other
people might think well a metaphysical
possibility has something to do with a
something that goes beyond Concepts and
what's involved in our Concepts and you
use the broad logical possibility
because you're not just relegating to
classical Logic No oh oh that's that
that's a no that's a good one too sorry
maybe I'll clean that up too by saying
broad logical possibility
it's what whatever logical system you
have in mind that could be classical or
paraconsistent or intuitionistic but you
have to add something else to it which
is the conceptual truths so broad
doesn't mean that it's not the important
part isn't what is the base logic it's
the conjunctive claim the claim that you
don't have just a base logic you have a
another thing conceptual truths that
you're putting together right and so
right so right so um I think Dave is a
first order logic plus conceptual truth
person and someone like you know if
Grand priest or France Berto was doing
this they'd be like well no it's
paraconsistent logic and then maybe we
add the conceptual truths and so there's
all these different players in this area
Tim Williamson has a different view too
and how it's done but yeah that's kind
of like um that's that's sort of the the
difference between those kinds of things
now now one of the things that is the
reason why this is done and this is
pretty much clearly the import move is
that we've always had this fundamental
question of like how do we know that
something is possible Right like how do
I know that something is this is like a
very interesting question because what
we mean by possibility here is not that
it's something that's actual and
therefore possible because what is
actual is possible but something that we
haven't
experienced and we know it's possible
Right so importantly in these debates
about Consciousness what was being
claimed is that it's possible for there
to be a physical duplicate of a human
particle for
particle structure and everything
exactly the same but it lacks phenomenal
Consciousness that's a philosophical
zombie right that's
conceivable and because it's conceivable
that's how we get to know it it's
possible so there's this idea that how
because you're not experiencing any
zombies in your life anytime soon or
would if we ran into one would we really
know what to think about its internal
States so someone is saying it's
possible for there to be such things and
that that's significant so how do we
know it's possible yeah we know it's
possible because uh we can conceive it
so conceivability is an important idea
that has been around in Western
philosophy as a way of knowing about
possibility that's so this is why this
is logic and um metaphysical thing is
this thesis is important about how you
inflate or deflate because it tells a
relational story to how you
know right is what you're saying
controversial that it's possible because
it's conceivable and the reason I say
that is again going back to Dan dennit I
believe he he or someone I'm sure you
can imagine you could conceive of
someone yeah who would say that it's
inconceivable that they're philosophical
zombies if they were to act like us in
every every single way and down to the
cells and so on they would feel like us
it's just impossible for it not to yeah
no this is very I mean so there's two
things that are controversial here and
you've touched on both of them one very
explicitly and the other one less
explicitly so the explicit one is
whether or not the claim that zombies
are conceivable is true or false okay
and the second one is who cares if it's
conceivable why should
conceivability give us an assurance or
knowledge that something is possible
okay so both of those are relevant I
particularly spent and still spend time
working on the second question I'm less
concerned with whether or not zombies
are conceivable yeah I'm more concerned
with this way in which our mind uses
something like
imagination conceivability
counterfactual
reasoning
intuition
deduction Theory based deduction in
order to come to know these claim so
that so so so I have I mean but it is
absolutely controversial and you're
right Dan dennet would say one thing
about the conceivability of zombies for
example the conceivability of zombies in
a very clear sense depends on how
much
information about the actual or the
hypothetical zombie do I have to have to
be in a position to make a
judgment that I've
conceived successfully conceived notice
like like so you know there's a you know
a famous you know example of
um by Peter vanwagon about uh Purple
Cows I mean like if I draw a picture in
my
mind of a cow and paint it purple is
that count as a conception of a purple
cow I mean I've done none of the details
about how cows could have evolved from
what they are actually have the
pigmentation that is purple and some I
mean like what is like if I just stick
something in my head and paint it I mean
if I take a p put some wings on it and
don't put it touching the ground is that
a flying is that a conception of a a
flying pig right so this is the this is
the issue is that how does I want to say
something that's hilarious many people
will say I invented that I invented that
app like six years ago I had the idea
for that app yeah but did you think
about the inner workings of that app did
you come up with a business plan for
that app did you hire people it's a
variation of that it is and also this is
the reason why it's related is because
we call this pro issue the problem of
relevant depth so what we say is that
there are ways of conceiving or
imagining certain things where the depth
of the imag ination and conception isn't
sufficient to make it the case that your
conception really counts for anything
right yeah so I could say you know I I
had this idea for this app many years
ago basically people would get on and
you know post things about their life
and share pictures and things like
that did I conceive a Facebook exactly
right so it's a relevant depth issue
except in your case a little bit of
what's going on is the aspect of having
credit for the idea in this case what's
happening is whether or not the depth is
sufficient to epistemically justify a
belief that something is possible should
I go around believing that there are
purple cows because I can paint pictures
of cows in my head
purple I don't know man doesn't sound
like that's really good evidence to me
so that's kind of the way I think about
the problem in that case yeah is that
what's behind when when some people say
look it's possible that the laws of
logic don't apply like it's conceivable
that they don't apply and maybe some
people say that when they've had some
experiences there are some ways you can
get to experiences like this with
psychedelics or medit that's that's a
that's a but then the counter would be
well how do you even know like what does
it even mean it doesn't make sense quote
unquote make sense someone else may
that's usually the intellectuals retort
to anything that doesn't make sense I
don't understand it one second well can
we just look at the that one was cool
was I like that
um no I don't think you have to be you
know backing off from this in a way of
saying like you're just generally
skeptical I think that
um it's conceivable that the laws of
logic
don't apply to this it's interesting
because to me what I get hung up on is
well what do you mean about the word uh
apply I mean if it applies or doesn't
apply isn't that because you've used
some logical reasoning to test whether
it applies or it doesn't apply so you're
saying to me it's conceivable ineffable
then it's not conceivable yeah
okay
um yeah there's there's a different
relationship between no actually let me
think for a second there is a
relationship between inconceivability
and ineffability in at least the
following sense if it's conce able that
P then it should be effable that P and
if it's inconceivable that P there
should be a sense in it's ineffable that
P right yeah that that does make sense
uh I was just worried about the use of
the word application yeah in that that
other case that's a little bit um hard
for me to but but I do think people do
want to say things like um it's
conceivably the case I don't even know
why they would have to say that but they
could say it's conceivably the case that
in this domain of
experience logic is uh inapplicable yeah
I can I can see yeah one of the ways to
see this is with the argument about can
God perform a contradiction and some
people say the stone Paradox yeah yeah
and so some people would say no because
the laws of God the laws of logic bound
God and other people would say he can
maybe he just doesn't or she doesn't or
it doesn't but it's possible yeah I mean
this is usually this is usually like in
that area where people say things about
can I rationally understand what God can
do so God can make it the case that he
can lift a stone that's so heavy that no
one can lift it by making it the case
that he changes the laws of logic
because he has the power to do that
because he created us and created logic
or people can say all that's happening
here is that logic is like that kind of
language thing that blocks me from
understanding what
is the the total space of possibility
because all I understand about
possibility is limited to me by my
ability to reason yeah that's that's not
an uncommon way of thinking that's
yeah so can you explain the integration
challenge oh oh okay oh wow okay okay so
integration challenge comes from
Christopher peacock in a book called
being known in some earlier papers and
the reliability challenge comes from
kind of Robert nosic but it can be found
elsewhere too um so the integration
challenge is the challenge of
harmonizing or integrating the
metaphysics and epistemology of modality
and
so the idea was that there was a problem
in the philosophy of mathematics that
existed in its own way in relationship
to
integration and then peacock kind of
applied it nicely into the space of the
philosophy of modality so if you have a
plag nistic theory of
mathematics then mathematical objects
are causally isolated from us but most
theories of knowledge think that if
you're knowing about
something you should have a causal
connection to it in some way either
directly or indirectly but given that
these platonic objects are cly isolated
we can never come to know them so that
platonic theory of mathematical objects
along with a causal constraint on
knowing is a
non-integrable theory of the philosophy
of mathematics we can't say that all
knowledge requires causal contact and
mathematical objects are causally inert
okay and expect to get an integrated
functioning theory of both the semantics
and epist the metaphysics semantics and
epistemology how is the word integration
being used here integration is being
used in the sense of Harmony in the
sense that they work they make sense
together I see not in the sense of
integration and calculus it does not
mean it means that the theory of
knowing makes sense in conjunction with
the theory of what those objects are
that they are so for example one of my
friends who I worked with for a long
time would have argued yeah it's clear
that what's going on here is that if you
have a plis theory of mathematics you
ought to say that ation in those cases
isn't related to knowing knowing doesn't
require causation in the case of
mathematics it does in the case of
ordinary concrete particulars in the
world such as perceptible objects but it
doesn't work in that case Okay so that's
that harmonizes well so now in the
philosophy of modality the claim was
that how we know about possible
worlds uh ought to be kind of consistent
with like what they are like if you if
you can't tell a theory yeah of what
they are are such as that we could know
about them so if you're David Lewis and
you think they're like these causally
isolated objects like uh uh in like the
the mathematical objects and Plato's
thing except concrete particulars are
causally isolated and how would we come
to know about them I mean like what
would be what what would be the
epistemology of them so that's the
integration challenge harmonize both the
metaphysics epistemology and semantics
of the domain of modality and then the
reliability challenge is I mean I kind
of had like a a big thing about this you
know back in around 2002 and 2004 I
worked a lot on this particular one more
than the integration challenge so one
version of it is kind of easy to sort of
tell the story of it's like okay so
Evolution gives us certain pressures on
our ways and methods of knowing okay so
there's like a a pressure like you've
got to get certain kinds of things right
if you're not able to detect edges of
cliffs reliably enough you're just going
to like not be able to stop yourself and
you're going to fall off the cliff or if
you're not able to reliably detect the
color of a tiger you're going to just
get eaten by one right so this is the
kinds of considerations which are
sloppily sort of just thrown about in
this debate but yeah that's roughly the
idea so then the the thing is like what
is the modal detecting faculty in your
brain why would we have evolved to get
something right in all possible worlds
when possible World variation is so
extreme like the I mean I can build
possible worlds in terms of different
laws of logic I can like why would there
be an evolutionary
pressure to get all of these things
right so the reliability challenge is to
explain the way in which our minds could
be reliable with the respect to the
acquisition of necessary truths and
merely possible truths truths that are
possible but not actually true and
truths are true and all possible are
necessary truths and so these two terms
were used more recently by Amy Thomasson
to sort of argue for new theories of
modality but they separately derived
from nosic and peacock I see yeah what's
a way around that it sounds Ironclad to
me oh sorry sorry right right you mean
about the second one yeah so oh yeah
there's an easy way around this I mean I
basically wrote one of the chapters of
my dissertation around this I think it's
I think those are just wrong it's
obvious yeah so there's something in
evolutionary theory called a spandrel
effect that is when you aim to produce
one thing explicitly you have a side
effect so it comes from the spandrels
that are in these little things and I
think it's a famous uh church right
where if you have two arches that cross
each other the intersection of those
arches will create four spaces right
okay all that was being done was we were
creating two arches but we got for free
this extra thing yes it's called spal
effect yeah uh and so yeah there is no
evolutionary press pressure to get
things right in all possible world but
there is an evolutionary pressure for a
certain kind of thinking that can take
us to reasoning about possibility so
this I think in my way is the Insight of
Timothy Williamson's view because he
says that the cognitive capacity that's
used is not imagination itself nor
conceivability itself but is based in a
reasoning capacity that is essential for
human survival uh it's called
counterfactual reasoning or
suppositional reasoning so
counterfactual reasoning is um basically
the ability to suppose something and
reason from it the classic example is if
the tree hadn't been there the rock
would have ended up in the lake that's
an example from his actual book but I
mean that's like totally relevant like
you if we couldn't reason like that if I
don't move to the left a little bit the
tiger will be close enough to jump and
get me if I move to the right my spear
trajectory will be a lot better like
naive physics in terms of hunting and
all this stuff requires counterfactual
reasoning so then the way I think I use
Williamson's view to defend or respond
to NOS because I say well once I have
counterfactual reasoning I can reason my
way to truths about metaphysical
modality and now there's Williamson Ox
offers a very rigorous mathematical
proof of the ability to get modal truds
Within counterfactual conditionals it's
a big part of his book uh but we can
suppress that for a moment take it for
me the proof works so but but the idea
is that okay Evolution will have given
us the capacity for counterfactual
reasoning but it's implicated in
everything we do scientific reasoning
ordinary reasoning hunting Gathering
everything there is a relationship
mathematically and provably between
metaphysical modality and counterfactual
uh conditionals Ergo there's a pathway
from those into
getting that so bye-by um you know the
challenge of uh evolutionary pressures
there remains a challenge about
explaining why it's reliable which is
actually something I work on right now
in terms of my own research still in
this field I I try to explain like how
the re reliability will be better or
worse but but the path so so we can take
the first version of the criticism to be
the pathway problem like what is the
path even to get there if they're
causely inert isolated from us and then
the other one is not about the pathway
being uh saying the pathway is present
the question is okay once you have a
pathway what will account for the
reliability uh so that we can be saying
we're making reliable judgments about
modal facts and so that's kind of what I
work on now but yes there is a way but
let's St let's make sure we're not
forgetting the other things so they're
related so the idea is that this is like
the hard problem of Consciousness which
I think you've heard of before right the
these aren't problem
problems in the sense of like what is 2
plus two there are problems in the sense
that you must give a satisfactory Theory
by obeying the constraints of
integration and reliability that's the
way that they're used so there are many
different theories so Amy Thomasson
defends a modal normativist Theory where
modality ends up being about Norms of a
certain kind uh other people offer I'm
an essentialist I defend an essentialist
theory in this Camp uh people offer like
lots of different but they're not
problems in the in that like how do you
solve it like that they're more like
what do you have to say about the hard
problem of Consciousness otherwise like
I don't only think you've given me a
theory right that's the kind of thing
like you got to say something here and
some things are more satisfactory than
others I don't particularly take the
reliability challenge as serious as I
take the integration challenges I think
you can considerations From Evolution
that don't specify a specific problem
Beyond uh the recognition of a spandel
effect seemed to me not that valuable
have you heard of Donald Hoffman yes I
know who Donald Hoffman is I believe he
talks about how our perception of the
world makes it the case that it's no
reality or something yes well the fact
that you would be mirroring reality is
the probability is zero essentially yes
that your perceptions would mirror
reality does that not put a monkey
wrench in the reliability challenge
um
well I mean the other side of this coin
is has to do with you
know
yeah I'm not going to
share his sympathies I mean I just have
a different theory of perception and I
think that it's it's not going to be
consistent with what he wants to say and
um there are a lot of moving parts so
the other aspect of my research is that
I work on like I said two things yeah I
think about how we know what's possible
and how we know what's actual like
that's like dominantly over 25 years of
my life I've worked in both of those
areas so I'm concerned with how we have
knowledge of non-actual possibilities
that are not given to us through
perception if I see a cup then I know
it's possible for there to be a cup
there that's an actual possibility that
actual fact that verifies the
possibility fact but what about your you
know potential sister or brother you
could have had that doesn't exist then I
think about how we perceive the world
ordinary objects and how that gives us
knowledge of the world and so I'm not
pretty much uh I don't think we need to
mirror the world in order to I don't I
don't think I mean that's not the
language I would use I'm sort of a
direct realist and uh I think perception
puts us directly in contact with the
objects like again so that whole idea in
chsky if we now bring it out in
perception that's not kind of where my
sympathy lies I I don't think in
language we're referring to things in
our head and I don't think in perception
we're talking about representations in
our brain I just don't think that's the
that's like a a confusion of a certain
kind to me a levels confusion what's a
levels confusion mean oh it means that
something that is like a category error
yeah that's I
mean no no no it is no no no no it's
okay to use um the famous example of a
category mistake uh from philos of to
help understand what a levels can in
some sense it is so yeah it is a
category mistake in that sense but
there's other things that could be going
on there it's just a it's a way of
saying that what is a correct way of
talking at one level doesn't really up
by at another level category mistakes
sometimes are a lot more severe than
that there's like saying you if I say uh
the number 16 has parents from Missouri
uh that's a category mistake because the
parent relationship literally understood
isn't a relationship the numbers have
right so there's a relationship between
that but you're right levels confusion
involves sometimes category mistakes um
so one of the things I learned in Indian
philosophy that is useful is that the
term praka which is a common translation
from sunscript into
perception can be used um both to refer
to the
process that starts with certain kinds
of things going on with your retina or
with contact with object in your
environment all the way up into
consciously like saying things but it
can also refer to the product of the
process which is like the state of
perceiving the cup in front of me and so
I think sometimes in the philosophy of
perception we tacitly engage in making
claims from one level to talking about
things at another level not maybe a
level's mistake or confusion but at
least we're transplanting things and
like this goes right back to the the
Buddhist like they're going to say
things like well you know the perceptual
processing involves a lot of stuff from
your mind being imputed to create your
conscious perceptual experience of
seeing the cup on the table and all that
perceptual processing is something
you're imposing that isn't really in the
world out there so you know as far as
your conscious perception is concerned
you're not tracking the world you're not
mirroring the world at all I mean the
thing that's relating you to the world
in the initial instance where your
system comes into contact with the world
that might be you know tracking
something or I guess they wouldn't use
mirroring either but it's clearly not um
mirroring it at the level of conceptual
imputation right so that's uh a thing so
I don't know exactly where Hoffman lies
on these issues but there's a family of
people in neuroscience and in the
philosophy of perception who like to
think of us as basically wet prediction
machines like that's the term I like to
use for this so Seth is one kind of a
person who thinks of us as wet
prediction needs for large part yeah I
think Hoffman is a little bit in that
camp I think friston is a little bit in
that camp I mean at least they talk that
way and I don't know how much they want
to load beyond that I'm not a wet
prediction theorist I don't I think
that's the right way to understand uh
the epistemological status of conscious
perceptual States it might be a way of
talking about some components of
modeling uh perceptual processing but
I'm not sure I see it as the right way
to think about uh conscious uh the
epistemology of conscious perceptual
States in which we make various claims
about the external World in order to
justify beliefs and engage in
argumentation with one another about the
structural reality I'm having a
difficult time help me boil this down to
an argument of against Dawn or against
denil yeah sure I can I think I think
but first of all I think maybe the
reason why you're having a hard time is
I haven't given an argument about
agreeing or disagreeing with any of
these people my position is not I
haven't laid anything out what I've
basically said is that I think there is
a way of scientifically
investigating the perceptual
process from V1 to V8 if you want to
talk in terms of those things or you
know retinal
stimulation uh up into the application
of beliefs and Concepts uh in the mind
or what the Indians would just talk
about perceptual context
versus or indeterminate perception
versus DET I'm actually writing a paper
on this indeterminate versus determinate
or what's called
Nala versus
sakaa two different types of
perception one with Concepts and one
without Concepts or what analytic
philosophers called non-conceptual
versus conceptual content in perception
uh yes I think that I think there's a
very important way in which we must look
at the evidence about the brain and how
it works in perceptual processing what I
was resisting was the idea that we can
automatically
transfer evidence we have about or
theories about perceptual processing to
say that when we have the conscious
experience of seeing a cup on a table
yes it just is somehow nothing over and
above or has no value epistemologically
over and above what is going on with the
perceptual uh um things so so for
example I would resist the claim that
there are no cups out there in the world
that were justified in believing in
based on the fact that all our system
does is predict based on our prior
experience with objects what would be
the most likely thing in our visual
field and feeds that up to our conscious
perception so I only see a cup because
the template in my perceptual stream is
a prior exposure osure has beanly
codified it however you want to say this
for um for uh you
know this thing coming up I don't um I
don't think that that's uh a good
inference right from one to the other
and I I will admit though that there is
a lot of pressure to to see it that way
there is a lot yeah explain that please
that's super interesting there's a lot
of pressure to explain it that way
because we have come to understand the a
certain model of our mind as engaging in
the world as kind of like it's odd
actually in some ways maybe this way of
sharing it with you will be insightful
and valuable like we want to draw this
distinction between us and like large
language models for example okay but but
but but when we talk this way that we're
prediction machines I seem like I feel
like we're like like is the big
difference that said basically unlike
large language models that may be doing
things more on the basis of syntactic
manipulation versus semantic
understanding were we the same with
prediction machines in terms of you know
doing something like that so I don't see
that that analogy um really works on the
one handed makes us much more closer to
the thing that everyone keeps on saying
we're fundamentally different from and
at the other time it seems like we're
forcing an inference from facts about
how a perceptual process works when it's
computationally modeled in a certain way
to what is the value of the experience
and it's not like there aren't any
debates about whether or not these sorts
of models are the best way to think
about it so there's like inactivist
theories of perception there's uh
indirect realist theories of perception
there's realist representationalist
theories there's a lot of different
things out there on the model and so I I
think that actually the the the
scientific research is very valuable and
probably one of the most important
things as a philosopher you have to pay
attention to I'm heavily influenced by
Tyler burge's work who has spent a lot
of time making sense of the
neuroscientific data and perception to
give an account of um perception but I'm
not sure like the story really ends
there for me like I think there's
there's more of a story that you have to
tell and so I I tend to want to go in
that direction as well
what are your thoughts on Free
Will
um what are my thoughts on do you feel
like there's pressure to go in the
direction of there is no free
will no it's actually the opposite I had
this really interesting dinner with
Richard swinburn one of the leading
philosophers of religion in the world I
had a dinner with him and my wife in um
Romania and uh we ended up talking about
Free Will and I just told them like I
never got into the problem of free will
because I I think I just was full blown
committed to the idea that uh Free Will
and determinism are
incompatible uh and we have free will uh
otherwise I can't make sense of yeah I
have maybe I'll repeat the same sort of
thing I said to him that I say to all my
students and everybody when they ask me
about free will there's two things about
Free Will I care about one is the thing
I'm about to say and the other is the
relationship again between artificial
systems and freedom and artificial
systems and Free Will in us so I'm very
interested in those so here's the first
one I think speaking a language and
communicating with someone is an
agential activity involving free will at
some level and degree of freedom in the
choice of constructing sentences and
embedding them with meaning to
communicate them so that if we don't
have free will I'm not talking right
now no there's nothing go it's a parot
there's nothing going on there right
right so parrots are merely under one
understanding simply repeating sounds
that they have heard without any sort of
choice about it in terms of the free
construction of meaning so if I don't
have so one way to make it clearly is
some people think about free will only
in relationship to bodily action I think
about Free Will in terms of its
relationship to mental action speaking
is a mental act so if I don't have free
will I don't have any mental actions if
I don't have any mental actions then I'm
not speaking because speaking is a
mental action that's the first point I
care about in terms of free wills I I
bring this up a lot um so um yeah then
the other one that I bring up is that
I'm not so sure that there's some kind
of free will that we have that machines
are incapable of having because they are
so-called quote unquote programmed in
some way and in fact I just saw this
wonderful episode of Star Trek it was in
the Voyager uhuh uh thff where they in
fact had a discussion between the Doctor
Who is a hologram and one of his
assistants and the doctor said to the
assistant um well I don't choose
anything when I give a diagnosis I've
been programmed to give the diagnosis
based on these vast amounts of
information
that I've been trained on like this is
this is the
Hologram talking to their assistant
about a patient that they have and
expressing himself that he doesn't have
choice or free will in diagnosis and
that he simply takes the data that's
been given to him runs it through all
the data he has known before or been
given and then spits out a diagnosis and
then she says This brilliant response
she says well what's the difference I
mean I went to medical school and I
studied all this stuff and basically
when they give me the information I try
to look at all the information in my
head and maybe the difference is that
it's more easily accessible to you
because your memory is so free flowing
with all its information and M is
forgetful but but isn't the fundamental
nature I thought this was one of the
most insightful philosophical episodes
of Star Trek because of you know how
this was expressed and so I thought yes
I do worry about that issue too about
the degree to which we really can run
the Charles Babbage lady Lovelace
objection against machines creativity
because it's all programmed in as the
initial objection goes that touring
responds to in his famous paper um yeah
so those are my two thoughts about free
will but I'm not a free will expert and
I know there are many people who talk
about in terms of quantum indeterminacy
and things like that I probably should
yeah withold about talking yeah is there
something about free will that makes it
sufficient for something something to
have moral
standing oh uh I don't think it's a
necessary condition I think it could be
an uh condition so yes I think yeah so
maybe like maybe this is something we
can get from free will into the other
thing that we kind of wanted to talk
about standing and moral grounding yeah
so I'll just sort of paint the picture
you know sort of synaptically what the
difference is between this is something
I actually do have something to
say I I like I have a positive thesis
more than just picking apart things I
don't like and writing papers like I I
definitely have strong feelings here I
so I don't think well you're so well
articulated that when you say that you
don't have something to say it's leagues
beyond what most people say when they
say I have something to say oh so your
threshold is so above yeah maybe my
threshold is too high then uh no so yeah
I think my view is that I don't yeah I
don't think that uh Consciousness is the
grounding property so on my view in my
research right now I think that there's
another property that's important it is
not free will though either it's not
free will so we might say that Free Will
is a sufficient condition for having
moral status but not a necessary
condition um but I think the property
I'm going to talk about now is more
basic and it's one that can explain
what's going on with free will maybe
want to explain the whole Theory so the
property I think is relevant is
computational intelligence that's gold
directed and tied to preferential States
so this goes back to the example of the
creature in the water can detect
magnetic north and south and tries to
get oxygen rich Water by going in one
dire and you call that cognition and to
me when I think of COG us to call it
cognitive suffering you're right sorry
when I hear the term cognitive I think
of a nervous system and I assume that
that's not what you mean I don't mean
that yeah no I don't so so again let me
explain here what's going on so I think
that there are lots of different um like
I always trying to find this word and I
never can find it like the word that
properly applies to biological and
nonbiological creatures I think
sometimes I just want to call them
natural versus artificial systems I mean
human is a natural system and a bug is a
natural system and an AI is an
artificial but I don't really like that
anyway you get the point there's like
these two different kinds of systems at
least and there are many different
versions of each kind there many
different artificial systems and large
language models are different than you
know domain specific uh chess playing
games and the different types of
creatures right yes so the thing that I
think makes something have that gives
something moral standing is that there
is a kind of intelligence in it that
involves
computations and that intelligence is go
directed and the system has preferential
States right so the little creature I
was talking about prefers to be an
oxygen rich environment opposed to the
oxygen low environment right it has a
detector for getting itself to that
thing it's not the greatest detector but
it does its job and I can mess with it
by putting a magnet over and then
killing it but the thing is it it it's
it's it's and that that detector is
giving it information that that has to
be computed then to move the it goes in
a certain direction right now I don't
know if the thing has phenomenal
Consciousness I don't if there's
something it's like for the thing to
detect magnetic north or south with that
that thing but but I know matter yeah
for me it doesn't because the thing is
it definitely prefers to be in the
oxygen rich environment over the low
oxygen yeah and so that should be enough
to say of that now look let's go further
so you understand like plants have
computational intelligence that's go
directed that involves preferences uh
lots of animals and insects above them
have the same preferences are different
than Tendencies is that
correct
um that's a good qu that's a good
philosophical question because sometimes
people say that Tendencies are this like
related to the philosoph the Free Will
thing Tendencies are a little bit more
automatic and preferences require
rational endorsement yeah I don't really
think I need to use preference in that
way this has a tendency to just want to
stay at the minimal position yeah so if
I raise it am I causing harm to
it this doesn't have moral standing
because it doesn't meet the artificial
life form yeah I get what I get I this a
good examples I get clearly exactly like
how it's challenging um I don't know I'm
not trying to challenge I'm just no no
no well I mean it's the right kind of
corner case to think about is what I
mean I mean in that sense yeah I
definitely think the answer is no that
that thing does actually not satisfy my
definitions but I think the reason why
it doesn't satisfy my conditions has to
do with the fact
that none of the things that are going
on with it have to do with anything
internal to the thing I mean obviously
it's gravity and mass alone that account
for the tendency so the use of the word
tendency is eliminable completely uh we
don't there's no tendency at all within
the object there's just the application
of the laws of physics to things that
have mass right there there's nothing
like it'd be one thing if it could had a
tendency or could
resist yes yes now Raymond smolan you
must know Raymond smolan I don't know
him personally but I definitely know who
he is yeah the logician yeah yeah yeah
he had this dialogue of man with God and
Free Will it was man arguing with God
saying hey why did you give me this free
will it's this huge imposition you did
this to me like take away my free will
then God's like okay if I do that then
you're going to commit maybe you'll
commit horrible crimes do you still want
me to take it away and the man's like no
because I'll be culpable now if I do
that but but you did this to anyway the
conversation then comes down to after
lines and lines and
lines God says you think of determinism
as somehow the world is so strong that
it just determines your
actions but what's the difference
between you and the world what's the
difference between you and law so if we
were to take that argument we could say
yeah okay well look it's just law of
gravity the law of gravity or some
minimization principle yeah but what's
the difference like where's the border
between this and the
minimization of action so yeah so there
is I don't know if this is well
formulated no no this is relevant no it
is because it's about the boundary of
what constitutes the system and the
creature so actually I read this
dialogue by Raymond SML and on this
channel along with commentary Link in
the description if you're someone one
who has this
uh wait there's multiple levels to get
at this um and I do think it's
completely relevant but I just want to
get into it from at least two different
levels so I guess here in this debate
I'm really just concerned with a
practical question I'm not being very
philosophical and so I'm inclined to say
that that that this is a metaphysical
question about what Mak something an
independent entity such that we can
ascribe moral standing to it and why is
this relevant you did it in terms of
like this way of talking about the
imposition and the boundaries but
there's another way of blowing apart the
whole debate about moral standing if
you're a Buddhist and you believe in
relational metaphysics and you think
everything is related to everything else
then what does it mean to talk about any
one given thing having moral standing
and something else not having moral
standing given that everything's related
to everything else right like often
times when I go to these Western debates
about moral standing uh I have to point
out to people because I've studied
nonwestern philosophy that pretty much
nothing they're talking about makes any
sense in relational metaphysics I mean
if everything is related to everything
else then if any one thing has a moral
standing everything else has moral
standing maybe a diluted small drop of
bgre right so this is the boundary
question now dressed up in the moral
status thing so I'm assuming because in
order to debate these people you have to
assume that some form of of uh
attribution of intrinsic moral uh moral
Worth to something makes sense so the
example I was given is that yeah you
know the Pig and the trough is related
to a whole bunch of other things it's
got little micro gut organisms too but
look it seems pretty clear we can talk
about the suffering of the pig and it
has some moral standing and some moral
worth we can kind of cut it away a
little bit and our cutting away allows
us to um discuss it in this way and so I
think I think that's I think that's
that's Rel so I think in order to play
this game we have to table the obvious
objection they may even turn out to be
the fundamental truth because here I
think relational metaphysics has a lot
going forward and the Buddhists have
cornered the market on some of this um
I'm willing to I'm willing to take that
as an objection but in terms of the way
the debate's proceeding my main goal is
to show that sentience defined in terms
of affective Consciousness or phenomenal
Consciousness depending whether you're a
narrow or broad theorist is just not
really the grounding property so this
part of my view is important for me to
pick out so I distinguish between what's
called a grounding property and a
grading property so a grounding property
says what it is in virtue of that some
system biological or not has moral
standing in the first place a grading
property says how do you grade it
relative to other things that have moral
standing so so there are two views here
if X and Y both have moral standing then
they have equal moral standing because
there is no notion of degrees of moral
status increasing and decreasing number
two if X and Y have moral standing then
it could be the case that X has greater
than y or Y has greater than x that's
the grading view so the grounding
property for me has nothing to do with
uh Consciousness at all it has to do
with computational intelligence that's
go directed and tied to uh preferential
states that are objectively measurable
in terms of the survival of the organism
or system whatever you want to say uh
and so now the grading properties this
will get you back to Free Will by the
way are properties like well above
having this computational intelligence
does that have phenomenal Consciousness
does have affective Consciousness does
have free will long-term rational
planning does it have emotional states
in addition which one of those does it
have as a collective CL uster like does
it just have emotional states and access
Consciousness but no phenomenal
Consciousness does it have some degree
of Free Will tied to its phenomenal
Consciousness but not a lot of uh Free
Will does it have low phenomenal
Consciousness but something else on a
high thing so it's called a cluster view
so the view is that grounding is
computational intelligence goal directed
tied to preferential States and then
grading is done in terms of clusters so
every system will instantiate some
cluster above the computational
intelligence and those clusters then are
metrized against each other such that uh
having one cluster puts you at one level
of moral standing having another cluster
puts you at another level of moral
standing and so there's a gradation so
it can be the case that artificial
intelligence is much more intelligent
than us and has a capacity for emotions
on my view as well but because they lack
some other thing that we have it turns
out that our cluster marks us as having
a higher moral standing than their moral
standing it could also turn out that
some large language models have greater
moral standing than some
insects even though those insects are
conscious or you know lobsters for
example may have the marking properties
for affective Consciousness the ability
to feel pain but no large language model
can it'll still be the case on my view
that we can metrize them because of the
cluster they instantiate maybe some kind
of cre have a high degree of free will
because they're biological and some uh
machines have a low degree of Free Will
so but but those same creatures can't do
certain other so you see the idea so the
idea grounding is computational
intelligence not Consciousness so I
disagree with all sentience theorists
and then grading is done in terms of
clusters and each cluster contains at
least two other properties and those
clusters then are weighted against each
other and they typically involve
emotionality affect feeling uh phal
Consciousness rational plan yeah that's
that's that's the general structure that
I've been working on for two years
something like that Anand what motivates
you to think about the subjects of
morality and possibilities so there are
several
possibilities of what you could be
interested in in the realm of Math logic
philosophy
language this is a person story that
might I think answer the question but
also be quite revealing in a way that
might trip you out a little bit um I was
I became interested in in studying about
how we know about what's possible really
early on like in 1990 um I 1996 when I
was in undergrad and um I it kind of
came to me as just like this problem
that Barkley the famous you know can you
conceive of a tree unconceived by anyone
that's that's a that's a that's a modal
argument actually based on
conceivability so I was like you know
modern philosophy class that was really
cool and interesting idea and sounded
like some problem and I was fascinated
by it and then I worked on it for a long
time so I was trying to really really
understand like all this stuff it was
only like 10 years ago or maybe 12 years
ago that I realized that I have a
Fantasia AIA same with Dan Dennett and
Yos shabach yeah so aant is you know
basically in some sense as applies to me
is like very low mental imagery for uh
you know imagination and states of Mind
in that sense and although recently must
say I've been eating a lot of cheese in
England and sometimes my mental imagery
pops right back I don't know about that
I don't know about that no internal
Voice or is that you do have one yeah no
no I see interesting yeah so then I
realized like wow it does make sense in
some weird Twisted way why I was so
interested in these theories of how
imagination gives us knowledge of
possibility because a lot of them except
for
Daves thought about the way in which we
know about possibility through
imagination through a pictorial theory
of imagination and I must have been
perplexed as a child how that could make
any sense CU I was like I don't know
having any picture of a pig with wings
or what are you talking about our Purple
Cow in my I don't what nothing is going
on how could this Theory Poss Dave was
one of the main people to distinguish
between objectual imagination and
propositional imag or objectual
conceiving and propositional conceiving
and I distinctions oh he has a lot of
good dis great philosopher and so I I
think that distinction that when I saw I
became fascinated with what it could do
because even though I didn't know I had
some condition it turned out that
actually that explained like sort of
like I was digging for like how would I
be someone who could understand
possibility if I don't have this
pictorial imagination so I think the
motivation for that historically and D
came the other one though is a little
bit different sorry it's a lot different
and the reason why it's a lot different
is because some of what motivated me to
start thinking about this problem about
machine emotions and moral grounding was
the sense that we were not thinking
critically so I started hearing people
talk I live in Silicon Valley in San
Francisco listen to people on podcasts
and you know discussion groups and the
height of the amount of um sort of like
um not arrogance or negligence to think
clearly about what the claims they were
making started to irk me a bit that I
started to just in my free time away
from my main philosophy and other I
started to think about this moral
grounding
problem and then I realized like that
there was a a gaping hole in the claim
that machines can't have emotion
and that they can't have any moral
status because they're not conscious uh
as I did more and more work and then
recently I've discovered that you know
there are other people actually who are
working on this problem who who who also
think the same thing I think I just
didn't know about them so I've recently
been in contact with Herman capellan
who's writing a new book on the topic of
uh agency and Ai and he and I share a
lot of the same views about whether or
not AI can have emotions and maybe even
like about how they have moral standing
so that sort of is how I got into that I
mean I have a long-standing interest in
the philosophy of Economics as it
relates to moral philosophy but that's a
different thing the this particular
interest came just from kind of being
tired of hearing people talk and
actually quite knowledgeable theorists
in the AI research Community were making
these claims and I and I just found
myself thinking like this just can't you
can't be saying so quickly that they
can't have emotions because they can't
feel that's a naive view of the
philosophy of emotions which has been
going on across multiple cult cult for
over 2,000 yes years like what do why
would you possibly assert that unless
you arrogantly assumed that that there's
only one theory of emotions and only one
way to talk about it's like everything
is about feeling and everything's about
phenomenal Consciousness there's nothing
else to talk about here and so because
they're made of silicon and silicon
things can't realize these states
there's nothing more to and I just
became like flabbergasted by the the
like I'm not even sure I believe
completely the machines can have
emotions but I have really good argument
that can show exactly a pathway to it
you don't see it so flippantly
dismissed I don't think we should be
flippantly dismissing it I don't think
we should be yeah I don't think that's
good that's bad critical thinking when
we're constructing and building
something that potentially has massive
ramifications in our everyday lives as
is already seen by what they can do well
when the machines take over you're going
to be on their good side that's for sure
maybe they'll be like all that on inv
viia guys like the Civil Rights he was
rooting for us he no well yeah I'm
theoretically thinking it through but
yes there is something to it that's
basically yeah those are the two sides
of those two
coins man we touched on Consciousness we
touched on AI morality Free Will physics
math God Indian philosophy Western
philosophy modality this is every topic
on the theories of everything channel in
one podcast did I do did I do a Theory
of Everything talk did I actually talk
about almost everything I you did a toll
podcast without actually explicating a
toe so that's the first oh that's that's
yeah I'm that thing is above my pay
grade I don't think I'm going to end
ever get there I'm sort of like in The
Theory of Everything by touching on
everything I'm a different toe I'm not a
theory of everything I'm a touch on
everything great great and next time we
can talk about Constructor Theory I know
you're gonna that conu yeah I've been
reading about that we'll do some
Constructor Theory next time yeah yep
and just for the audience the reason is
that you study modalities and
counterfactuals so possibilities
impossibilities necessary yeah the other
one you're going to like is in the
future we should talk about this theory
that uh has been floated around recently
that back when I was in grad school in
the 90s people kind of knew about this
but they didn't really work on it and I
don't know why but now it's more
available and that's the idea that the
philosophy of physics that is closely
related to actual physics in terms of
working is just the philosophy of
modality view so Alistar Wilson I think
has written the most recent book sort of
articulating this but it was something
we kind of already kind of thought about
like the many worlds interpretation in
terms of looking at um possible World
semantics way yeah like it was so next
time we can probably try and like work
through some of that and I think you'll
find that that's actually probably in
some way related to The Constructor
Theory stuff yeah when I heard that if
you didn't attach the name Alistair to
it I wouldn't have thought it was that
person I would have thought it was K
marletto oh I don't know that person K
Marl is the founder or developer of
Constructor Theory along with David
Deutsch oh oh right so I'm not
mentioning Constructor Theory I'm
mentioning the theory and fos modality
that yeah could be related to the idea
that philosopy of physics and philosophy
of modality are very closely intimately
related in that both of them are trying
to tell us something about possibility
uh in a very important way yeah yes they
are related to Constructor Theory have
here's something that I was thinking
about so in modal logic it looks to me
like there's so much symbol manipulation
like there's these squares and P's and
and there's something called lobes
theorem or LS
theorem anyhow the proof for LS theorem
or Lopes theorem it's quite contrived I
don't have an intuition for it I can
follow it with the symbols like okay
these are the rules and it seemed to me
like modal logic and or doxastic logic
is done in a different different way
than regular math and I wanted to know
if my perception is correct as an
outsider so regular
math is done where you walk and you
think about subjects and you relate them
then you you have some insight you go
back to the Blackboard and you try and
find the words to put to the ideas and
see if it matches the words meaning the
symbols sorry now in modal logic it
looks like category Theory to me where
there's it's the opposite it's the
symbol pushing and then at the end then
you're like okay now what does this
actually mean
okay now is that perception correct or
no okay so
there it could become more complicated
than it needs to be but I'm going to do
the version that's very straightforward
given the way you describe this but you
understand what I'm saying oh I
understand something that is extremely
relevant here that studied it's the
difference between proof Theory and
model Theory that's the difference as I
understand between so uh I don't think
so the difference between how articulate
is that there is nothing um that says I
have to think when I'm doing stuff in
modal logic proof theoretically versus
so let me explain what that means proof
theoretically means I'm thinking about
more or less proofs and symbol
manipulation I don't care what these
things symbols on the board means
they're just I'm moving around boxes and
squares and diamonds boxes and diamonds
and parentheses based on rules given in
the axium system if I'm in an S4 modal
logic system I have transitivity if I'm
in a b system you know I'll have
symmetry and I won have transitivity and
I'm S5 I'll have the ukil property and
these are like
rules um uh in model Theory I'm thinking
about something more semantic more
meaning related right and so I can
approach doing my logic in these
different ways and different
theorists in the history of the
philosophy of logic have preferred one
of these over the other they have
preferred to be proof theoretic people
as opposed to model theoretic people or
they've proved to see or they they've
seen a value in each of them um right so
I definitely think that's correct but
what I don't think is a correct
perception is like like as if like I
didn't like I wouldn't say like there's
some way in which you're moving around
these symbols and then you're forced as
only at the end what does this mean
there is a way in which when you started
by saying modal logic and doxastic logic
um I did understand this claim so let me
clarify that um like I
can follow a
system
S5 as it relates to proving things and I
can do proofs and then I can ask myself
at the end if the Box means metaphysical
modality what have we shown if the Box
means know and the diamond means
believe then what have we shown because
boxes and diamonds I mean I guess I I
learned this a little bit the language I
just called like there's like an algebra
like there's an algebra of how to move
these things around but then I can take
the algebra and I can uh interpret it
like there an operator algebra like how
can I use the box and what can I do and
then there's what can the box mean like
so for example in deontic logic we don't
always use boxes and diamonds we use
like the letter O capital letter O for
obligation and another letter for
permissible but D but deontic logic is
about the modality concerning should and
should not it's about the moral it's not
about the metaphysically modal so athic
modality and doxastic is about belief
knowledge du sastic States um so in
general we have this idea that there are
certain theorems that a doxastic logic
will satisfy well a modal logic this
about metaphysical for example satisfy
something else and deontic logic and so
I typically use the word uh athic
modality to signify the kinds of things
that I'm talking about but I I wouldn't
I wouldn't yeah I wouldn't say that
other thing you said about like I don't
know I mean maybe unless there's
something about C or Theory I don't
really know a lot about it at least
terms of my studying of modal logic
there's that says I have to like I can
start my proof and say oh box p means
it's necessary that P and Diamond p
means it possible to p and I can work
through the whole proof and think about
it that way and in fact I might even
have more insights about how to think
about proving it based on having it mean
something as opposed to just figuring
out how to do it uh with symbols yeah so
yeah that's my the simple way of me
understanding what's going on there and
so I wouldn't say like there's some
difference with the oh maybe the way
you're categorizing the difference
between how you do certain things in
mathematics and how you do certain
things in logic is that there's a level
of
abstraction that's a little bit more
removed in the logic case and actually I
think that actually might be accurate
because the domain of what you're
talking about so when you're talking
about logic in a lot of ways in terms of
certain things you're talking about
rules of logic which basically I'll give
you the name it's called the the fun
conception of logic unfortunately the
word fun probably doesn't mean what you
think it means because logic isn't Fun
For A lot of people the fun conception
of logic means that logic is formal
Universal and topic neutral okay it's a
way of thinking about what
logical truths are about so a or not a
is fun because it's formal applies to
everything Universal and topic neutral
it's neutral about what topic is the fun
conception of logic is that level of
abstraction back that might be something
that um you don't find a lot of a like
you know topology is probably about
spaces of some kind and blah you know
whatever I'm not a mathematician but you
get the idea this is a little bit higher
up and Abstract however I will say this
although I was taught and trained Under
The View that their logic is fun in a
sense I don't agree with that view at
all I'm more in line with the kind that
Timothy Williamson has argued where
logic clearly is making substantively
important claims about how what's going
on it does have some infection into the
things the fact that the symbols of the
system have a property of being
permutation and variant over various
domains this permutation and variance
isn't really making it it fun so yes so
that's a that's a big Topic in
philosophy of logic but but yes there's
the way in which you're saying it could
be different because of how you think
about what you're doing and what you're
operating with in terms of having a
level of abstraction I think that that
can be understood this way so I have
another large question that I'll just
say and if you could say it shortly yeah
then State your answer shortly but if
not we'll save it for the next time is
there a view of both deflationary and
inflationary so that is that physics is
equivalent to metaphysics which is
equivalent to logic so max Tech Mark
maybe says that logic and math sorry
physics and math are the same same with
Wolfram
Maybe right I got it so so is there
someone who's saying no no not that not
as as I understand the space of how this
is debated that that they are one in the
same and nor nor would I be that much uh
inclined to think that
what Max and Stephen are
saying is directly related to for
example what David I Sydney Shoemaker
and like Brian Ellis are talking about
because it's it's it's not about a
generic wider notion of mathematics it's
very specified to a certain
understanding of logical systems the
notion of conceptual truth the notion of
what is it trying to get at when we say
metaphysical modality and kry Key's
naming a necessity and what actually
makes sense so the the collapse paper by
gr priest where he argues for skepticism
about the reality of metaphysical
modality is kind of like a really good
place to look to see like what are the
kinds of ways in which people push back
on this sort of idea that metaphysical
modality cards a joint in the space of
possible worlds that's distinct from
logic I see and physics but but there is
there there is a relationship
of people wanting to say this other
thing which you might have wanted to say
where they're saying there's two ways of
looking at it right so if I look at it
one way I can see the physical
possibilities just are the metaphysical
possibilities and if I switch my
orientation I can see that there're just
The Logical possibilities that hasn't
really been developed because it hasn't
been relevant in the debates so far but
I mean if someone wanted to go
anti-realist and say that really whether
something turns out to be physically
possible or metaphysically is all
relative to the orientation or the
framework we put upon it uh that's an
anti-realism that they could go for I'm
not that kind of anti-realist uh but
yeah that would be a way to do it last
question docs asked a question question
if you believe P do you then believe
that you believe P oh no no I don't
think that's true yeah no definitely not
because because because and that's an
important principle that I think reveals
a lot and it's very useful that you ask
that P specific version of the S4
iteration principle because that doesn't
make sense iteratively at all so now so
the reason why I don't like that
principle is for two reasons basically
is applied to belief the asarum is
applied to belief is
because if you believe that P it might
be the case that the requirements for
belief have never been exercised such as
to generate that you believe that you
believe the P right so it's the first
thing like if I believe that water is
wet what does it take to generate the
belief that I believe that water is
reflect do I just still think about
water being wet whether I believe that
or do I have to think about whether or
not I believe that water is wet seems
like I have to embed the first order
claim and I don't know what the
generation conditions are or that we
often enough do that so it could be
because I believe that P but I just
never bother to reflect on whether I
believe as opposed to doubt that I
believe the P so there's an interesting
argument to be had there which makes me
resist wanting to endorse it but more
importantly as I I as I argued uh as I
as I endorsed my professor's view when I
was an undergrad
I just don't think iteratively it makes
sense I'm very much against the idea
that it makes sense that uh there's
something going on and I say that I
believe that I believe that I believe
that I believe that I actually had this
argument and debate with Timothy
Williamson one time where we were
talking and he's like yeah on it doesn't
it iterate isn't there like a you know
an obvious sense in which we can say
that it iterates uh up to that many and
I was like I don't think it makes any
sense I think it makes sense to say you
believe the P it maybe even makes sense
to say you believe that you believe the
P once you get to the third one thinking
everything after that just collapses
down
to the first one and so there's this
idea also that an S4 Modo Logics
iteration collapses but it seems to me
that that cuts in the other way because
believing that you believe that P does
seem to be substantially different than
believing that you pee believing yes I
understand yeah yeah so so so so it's a
nice one I think it's a good object
lesson when we're teaching how modal
operate the operator algebra of boxes
and diamonds can be interpreted
differently to get different results
because look there the famous T ation
says box P then P if you interpret box
to be belief that's clearly false if you
believe that P doesn't fall p is true
but if you interpret box to be necessity
well if it's necessary the P then p is
true that seems like analytically and
obviously true yeah so your lesson is an
extremely important one because it
teaches people to realize that unless
you have an OP a model an understanding
of what the box is you're going to get
different theorems that are that's right
that makes perfect sense yep speaking of
believing in P I haven't used the wash
him in a while so okay got to get going
and also I think that the BP implies bbp
is Central to the debate between Jordan
Peterson and Sam Harris I think that's
what Jordan pet so if you believe P then
you believe that you believe P oh bbp
thenes
bbp oh sure there right that's just I I
think that's false as far as my
understanding is Sam Harris says yes
that's obvious and Peterson says no
that's not obvious that's false like
wait a minute Sam Harris says that BP no
no no no this is my inference from their
debate oh yeah I don't I don't right
right uh yeah and even actually uh yeah
we can do the the other one if you
believe that you believe that P do you
believe that P maybe that one that one
seems a little bit more like I could
step my foot into it
although I still think there could be
issues about the the release from the
belief to the belief that P but if you
believe that P you believe that you
believe that p man that's probably a
person's dissertation in my opinion if
it hasn't already been written all right
and then it was so much fun four hours
four hours like it went by like hey man
you asked great questions you know what
you're doing man it's a fun time what
can I say thank you and you give great
answers thank you okay man all right the
episode is now concluded if you like
this episode I encourage you to check
out the Lawrence Krauss episode on cloud
entities what it takes to live forever
physically speaking it's a dysonian
thought experiment about can we in
principle live forever despite the heat
death of the universe it's the most
technical interview Krauss has ever done
that's what he said on air and this is a
huge compliment considering he's done
over 400 interviews there's also the
yosa bach and Ben goril podcast that
one's on AI Consciousness and AI
timelines and of course there's part one
with Anan via where he gives his talk on
moving beyond non-dualism and
integrating Indian modes of thought as
well as Concepts from the vadic
tradition into the AI Consciousness
conversation thank you the podcast is
now concluded thank you for watching if
you haven't subscribed or clicked that
like button now would be a great time to
do so as each subscribe and like helps
YouTube push this content to more people
you should also know that there's a
remarkably active Discord and subreddit
for theories of everything where people
explicate toes disagree respectfully
about theories and build as a community
our own toes links to both are in the
description also I recently found out
that external links count plenty toward
the algorithm which means that when you
share on Twitter on Facebook on Reddit
Etc it shows YouTube that people are
talking about this outside of YouTube
which in turn greatly AIDS the
Distribution on YouTube as well last but
not least you should know that this
podcast is on iTunes it's on Spotify
it's on every one of the audio platforms
just type in theories of everything and
you'll find it often I gain from
re-watching lectures and podcasts and I
read that in the comments hey toe
listeners also gain from replaying so
how about instead Rel listening on those
platforms iTunes Spotify Google podcast
whichever podcast catcher you use if
you'd like to support more conversations
like this then do consider visiting
patreon.com Kurt jongle and and donating
with whatever you like again it's
support from the sponsors and you that
allow me to work on tow full-time you
get early access to ad free audio
episodes there as well for instance this
episode was released a few days earlier
every dollar helps far more than you
think either way your viewership is
generosity
enough